and welcome to your second drink of Survivor Man. This episode written by Steve Correll has Michael going out into the woods and Jim planning birthdays in the office. And Angela, this was also the episode where you revealed that you have a summer birthday that never got celebrated. I know, and I'm really like to see about it. Well, we got so much mail from people who related to this. And we've talked about this on the podcast before. you got inundated with birthday cards that year for your birthday. I mean, our mailbox was full. Yeah, I was so moved by it. I had no idea people would latch onto this. I have a stack of them. I saved.
欢迎收听第二期《幸存者曼》。这一集由史蒂夫·卡瑞尔编剧，讲述了迈克尔去树林里探险，而吉姆在办公室策划生日派对的故事。安吉拉，这一集也是你透露自己夏天过生日却从未被庆祝过的那一集。我知道，我真的很想聊聊这个。嗯，我们收到了很多读者的来信，他们都深有同感。我们在播客里也谈过这件事。那年你的生日，你收到了海量的生日贺卡。我的意思是，我们的邮箱都塞满了。是的，我真的很感动。我没想到大家会这么关注这件事。我保存了一大摞。
It was really sweet. People were like, we will never let Angela's birthday go uncelebrated again. And there were cards with donuts on them and like humming birds, like all the things that you guys have heard me talk about. It was really great. And I have to say, you guys, guys, we're like, Ange, that's it. We do birthdays on office ladies. We're never going to let one pass. We have celebrated your birthday every year ever since. All of our birthdays. Yes. Well, we also got a lot of mail about the birthday storyline in this episode. Brian G. wrote in and said, hi, you gals are pretty cool. Thanks, Brian. Anyways, in Survivor Man, Angela says that for birthday month, it's Creed's birthday today. Oscars is a week after next and Meredith's is at the end of
这真的很贴心。大家说，我们绝不会再让安吉拉的生日被忽略了。还有印着甜甜圈和蜂鸟的贺卡，就像你们听我提到过的那些东西一样。这真的很棒。我必须说，伙计们，我们当时就说，安吉拉，就这样吧。我们在《办公室女士》里要过生日。我们绝不会错过任何一个。从那以后，我们每年都庆祝你的生日。我们所有人的生日。是的。嗯，我们也收到了很多关于这一集生日剧情的来信。布莱恩·G写道，嗨，你们这些女孩真酷。谢谢你，布莱恩。总之，在《幸存者曼》中，安吉拉说生日月里，今天是克里德的生日。奥斯卡的生日在下下周，梅雷迪斯的生日在月底。
the month. But in the Alliance, when Michael is looking to throw a morale-boosting birthday, Pam says that the next birthday, which is Meredith's, isn't until next month. Is this a continuity error that the writers just forgot or missed? And Allie G. Norris C. Will T. and Laura S. also all wrote in about this. It was a true fan mail flurry. I get it. It makes sense. I think this was just a continuity error. Yeah, I agree. Because yes, if Michael was looking for someone's birthday, and if Creed, Oscar, and Meredith's birthday are all in the same month, why would we have to wait till the next month for Meredith's birthday? Wouldn't Creed or Oscar's birthday be up next, right? That's what they're saying. Yeah. Yeah. Well, Caroline C says,
但在《联盟》那一集中，当迈克尔想要举办一个提振士气的生日派对时，帕姆说下一个生日，也就是梅雷迪斯的生日，要到下个月才到。这是一个编剧忘记或遗漏的连续性错误吗？艾莉·G、诺里斯·C、威尔·T和劳拉·S也都写信提到了这一点。这真是一场粉丝来信的狂潮。我明白了。这说得通。我认为这只是一个连续性错误。是的，我同意。因为是的，如果迈克尔在找某人的生日，如果克里德、奥斯卡和梅雷迪斯的生日都在同一个月，为什么我们要等到下个月才过梅雷迪斯的生日呢？难道不应该是克里德或奥斯卡的生日先到吗？他们就是这么说的。是的。是的。嗯，卡罗琳·C说，
hi, ladies, just thought it was funny that the party planning committee were not organized for Creed's birthday. Surely they would have at least asked him the day before what he would like or have it ordered beforehand. Angela only announces to Jim that they need to order a cake for Creed on the day, which seemed like she had left it to the last minute. Uncharacteristic. Yeah, I saw this letter and I had to go back because this is season four, Survivor Meena's Season 4. Jim and Dwight are not in charge of the party planning committee until season 5. That's when they do the lame birthday for Kelly. Right. But Michael has put Jim in charge of the birthdays when he leaves. What's going on? Why wasn't Angela in charge of this party? And it's true.
嗨，女士们，只是觉得派对策划委员会没有为克里德的生日做好准备很有趣。他们肯定至少会在前一天问他想要什么，或者提前预订。安吉拉只是在当天才告诉吉姆他们需要为克里德订一个蛋糕，这看起来像是她拖到了最后一刻。这不符合她的性格。是的，我看到了这封信，我不得不回去查了一下，因为这是第四季，《幸存者曼》是第四季。吉姆和德怀特直到第五季才负责派对策划委员会。那是他们为凯利举办那个糟糕生日派对的时候。没错。但迈克尔在离开时把生日派对交给了吉姆负责。这是怎么回事？为什么安吉拉不负责这个派对？这是真的。
Why didn't she already have this planned? It's all very suss. You think it's suss? Well, when Jim goes around and he's trying to plan all these birthdays, because he's going to combine them all into one day, isn't it Kevin who says he wants a Fudgy the Whale cake? Yeah. And you ended up doing a deep dive on Fudgee the Whale and Carvel cakes,
为什么她没有提前计划好？这一切都很可疑。你觉得可疑吗？嗯，当吉姆四处奔走试图策划所有这些生日时，因为他要把它们合并到一天，难道不是凯文说他想要一个“鲸鱼软糖”蛋糕吗？是的。然后你最终对“鲸鱼软糖”和卡维尔蛋糕进行了深入研究，
and we got two comments on that. Aaron B would like us to know that apparently there is a Fudgy the Whale beer. What? if only Kevin knew. Maybe that's why Kevin suggested the cake. And Amy S said, I want to say that puss is slang for face. So the cake cookie puss that you were wondering about, Angela, it could mean cookie face. Oh.
我们收到了两条关于此的评论。亚伦·B想让我们知道，似乎有一种“鲸鱼软糖”啤酒。什么？如果凯文知道就好了。也许这就是凯文建议那个蛋糕的原因。艾米·S说，我想说“puss”是脸的俚语。所以安吉拉你好奇的那个“饼干猫”蛋糕，可能意味着“饼干脸”。哦。
Yeah. So after looking at the picture, Amy thinks that it's a cookie face cake, not a cookie cat cake. Okay, that makes more sense. Okay. Well, good to know. You guys know after this episode aired, I was working on a show called Deliciousness, and they brought a fudgy the whale cake to me. They did? Yeah, they made it as one of the desserts because the guy that did the catering.
是的。所以看了照片后，艾米认为那是一个饼干脸蛋糕，而不是饼干猫蛋糕。好吧，这更有道理。好吧。很高兴知道。你们知道吗，这一集播出后，我正在做一个叫《美味》的节目，他们给我带来了一个“鲸鱼软糖”蛋糕。他们真的带来了？是的，他们把它做成了甜点之一，因为负责餐饮的那个人。
His wife is a huge office ladies fan, and he was going to get a dessert, and she was like, you should get a fudgy the whale cake. Well, I think that is very sweet. I did too. And thoughtful. Very thoughtful office ladies listeners out there. Well, listen, in this episode, I also talk about a runner of deleted talking heads. about all the birthdays. I didn't play them, but they were added back to the superfan version, so I thought we could hear those today. It's birthday month. This month, there are four birthdays
他的妻子是《办公室女士》的忠实粉丝，他本来要准备甜点，她就说，你应该买个“鲸鱼软糖”蛋糕。嗯，我觉得这非常贴心。我也这么觉得。而且很周到。非常周到的《办公室女士》听众。嗯，听着，在这一集中，我还谈到了关于所有生日的被删减的采访片段。我没有播放它们，但它们被添加回了超级粉丝版本中，所以我认为我们今天可以听听这些。这是生日月。这个月，办公室里有四个生日，
in this office. Guess why? Count back nine months. Valentine's Day. Stagger your sin, people. Oh, I hate my birthday. I am so old. I mean, I'm still so much younger than everyone else who works here, but they're like elderly. Pam lies a better age. I usually have a very nice birthday after work with my friends who do not work here. I don't enjoy my birthdays the way I used to. This year I've decided to call in sick.
猜猜为什么？往回数九个月。情人节。大家错开你们的罪恶吧。哦，我讨厌我的生日。我太老了。我的意思是，我仍然比这里工作的其他人年轻得多，但他们就像老年人一样。帕姆谎报了一个更好的年龄。我通常在下班后和不在公司工作的朋友过一个非常愉快的生日。我不像以前那样享受我的生日了。今年我决定请病假。
All right, I have lots of things to discuss about these talking heads. Angela Judgy, as usual. But Kevin has a whole other life outside this office of friends that he goes and hangs out with. He's in a band. It's true. a full life. He has his whole like poker playing buddies. He's got his band buddies. I buy it. He's just a little social butterfly. I mean, look at him in the finale when he's running his bar.
好了，关于这些采访片段，我有很多话要讨论。安吉拉一如既往地爱评判别人。但凯文在办公室外有完全不同的生活，有他一起出去玩的朋友。他还在一个乐队里。这是真的。生活很充实。他有他那群打扑克的朋友。他有他的乐队伙伴。我相信。他只是个小社交蝴蝶。我的意思是，看看大结局里他经营酒吧的时候。
I think Kevin really comes alive outside of the office. Yeah. Well, listen, you might recall this is also the episode where Dwight reveals all of his hidden weapons around the office. Yeah. We did discuss this, but we got a great letter of extra tidbits from Mark P. Okay, great. Mark starts by saying, I can't believe you guys glossed over the filing cabinet knife file. You mentioned the knife but didn't mention the file it is in, which is Mr. A. Knife. Mark goes on to say you also glossed over the biggest question about the blowdart gun. Why did he store the blow dart gun, which has to be put in his mouth in a toilet tank? Ew.
我觉得凯文在办公室外真的活过来了。是的。嗯，听着，你可能还记得这一集也是德怀特揭露他在办公室里藏的所有武器的一集。是的。我们确实讨论过这个，但我们收到了马克·P发来的一封关于额外花絮的精彩来信。好的，太棒了。马克首先说，我不敢相信你们竟然忽略了文件柜里的刀具档案。你们提到了刀，但没有提到它所在的档案，也就是“A先生刀具”。马克接着说，你们还忽略了关于吹箭筒最大的问题。为什么他要把必须放进嘴里的吹箭筒存放在马桶水箱里？咦。
Disgusting. Oh, that's a good catch. Why wouldn't that be one of the things in a file or a drawer? Put something else in the toilet tank. Mark says definitely intentional by the writers to make it more crazy. And then Mark said, Angela, you wondered what the pitchfork nice thing is. It is called a sigh.
真恶心。哦，这真是一个好发现。为什么那不应该是放在档案或抽屉里的东西之一呢？把别的东西放进马桶水箱里吧。马克说这绝对是编剧故意设计的，为了让它更疯狂。然后马克说，安吉拉，你好奇那个干草叉一样的东西是什么。它叫“钗”。
Mark said, I know it looks like an offensive weapon, but I've been told by friends who do martial arts that it is a primarily defensive weapon. Huh. The middle prong is usually blunt. so you can hold it, quote unquote, upside down along your forearm to block attacks. Okay. Finally, we had wondered about the Ziploc bag full of pellets in Dwight's desk.
马克说，我知道它看起来像是一种攻击性武器，但我从练武术的朋友那里听说，它主要是一种防御性武器。哈。中间的叉齿通常是钝的，所以你可以把它“倒着”握在你的前臂上以阻挡攻击。好吧。最后，我们对德怀特桌子上那袋装满颗粒的密封袋感到好奇。
We were like, what are these pellets? Mark P said, I'm not sure about the pellets either, but one additional possibility is that it could be wood pellets used as a fire starter, like the kind that are sometimes used in grills. Yes, that makes so much sense, right? Yes, not naughty oats, actual pellets. Yes, exactly. Well, we also apparently miscounted the weapons.
我们当时想，这些颗粒是什么？马克·P说，我也不确定这些颗粒是什么，但另一种可能性是，它们可能是用作引火物的木颗粒，就像有时在烤架上用的那种。是的，这太有道理了，对吧？是的，不是那种恶作剧的燕麦，是真正的颗粒。是的，完全正确。嗯，我们似乎还数错了武器。
Luciano J. wrote in to say, guys, Dwight has 24 weapons. In the office, you are missing the crossbow that he takes from under the sofa at reception. Oh. Well, that was really good, you guys. Mm-hmm. Thanks for all those catches. I have a fun little thing that Vito P wrote in, Lady. Are you ready for this?
卢西亚诺·J写信来说，伙计们，德怀特有24件武器。在办公室里，你们漏掉了他从接待处沙发下拿出的那把弩。哦。嗯，那真的很棒，伙计们。嗯哼。谢谢你们所有的发现。维托·P写了一件有趣的小事，女士。你准备好了吗？
Yes. Vito says, you guys should have a YouTube show called Office Ladies Day Off, where you go and do all the things you guys say, quote, we should go do this on the podcast, like Blow Dark classes, cruise ship factory, etc. Did we say we wanted to go to a cruise ship factory? We did. And we also said we wanted to take a Blow Dart class. Among other things, we've said a bunch of these. And Office Ladies Day Off sounds really fun to me. Same. It sounds fun to me too. You know what? We almost did in St. Louis over the holidays. Is axe throwing?
是的。维托说，你们应该做一个叫《办公室女士休息日》的YouTube节目，在那里你们去完成你们在播客里说的所有事情，比如“我们应该去参加吹箭课程”、“去游轮工厂”等等。我们说过想去游轮工厂吗？我们说过。我们还说想去上吹箭课。除其他事项外，我们说过很多这样的事情。《办公室女士休息日》听起来对我来说很有趣。我也是。听起来也很有趣。你知道吗？我们在假期去圣路易斯时差点就做了。是扔斧头吗？
Oh, I did that in Iceland. Yeah? Yes. Me and Josh and the kids did axe throwing in Iceland. So we went to eat dinner one night at this place that was made to look like a true authentic Viking hall. It was so dimly lit. We could barely see our food. So you go in, you put your order in and there's these long, long banquet like tables with benches. Like you would. Like a meat hall, like a Viking meat hall. And while you're waiting for your food, they had this little side area where you could just go throw axes. So we did. And I got it. I got it in the thing. Was the axe throwing area also dimly lit? It was a little bit more lit.
哦，我在冰岛做过那个。是吗？是的。我和乔什还有孩子们在冰岛扔过斧头。所以有一天晚上我们去这个地方吃晚饭，它被设计成看起来像一个真正地道的维京大厅。灯光非常昏暗。我们几乎看不见我们的食物。所以你进去，点餐，那里有长长的、长长的宴会桌，配着长凳。就像你会在……就像一个肉食大厅，像一个维京肉食大厅。当你等食物的时候，他们有一个小侧区，你可以去扔斧头。所以我们做了。我做到了。我把它扔进去了。扔斧头的区域灯光也很昏暗吗？稍微亮一点。
But where you ate was dimly lit. It was very Beowulf. I'm like, where's Grindle? Well, that all sounds pretty fun to me. Yeah. All right, everyone. Here is your second drink of. of Survivor Man.
但你吃饭的地方灯光很昏暗。非常有《贝奥武夫》的感觉。我在想，格伦德尔在哪里？嗯，这一切听起来对我来说都很有趣。是的。好了，各位。这是你们的第二杯《幸存者曼》。
I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories
我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并提供独家的幕后故事，
that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hi, everybody. Hello. Are you guys ready for this episode today, Survivor Man? Do you have your duct tape? Oh, boy. That's probably...
只有两个在场的人才能告诉你。我们是《办公室女士》。嗨，大家好。你好。你们准备好迎接今天这一集《幸存者曼》了吗？你们带胶带了吗？哦，天哪。那可能是……
Oh, man. Do you have your duct tape and a Ziploc bag full of what were those? Peanuts? I have so many questions about it. Pellets? Granola? We don't know. And maybe a bow knife? Definitely a knife. Definitely always a knife for Survivor Man. I forgot to eat breakfast this morning before we got ready to record this podcast, Angela. So right before this moment, I ran downstairs and I ate an egg and a half of an apple. It hasn't digested yet, so I feel a little loopy. I feel a little bit like I'm in a good space for this episode.
哦，天哪。你有胶带和一个装满……那是什么？花生？我对它有很多疑问。颗粒？格兰诺拉麦片？我们不知道。还有可能是一把弓刀？绝对是一把刀。对于《幸存者曼》来说，绝对总是一把刀。我今天早上录制这个播客之前忘了吃早餐，安吉拉。所以就在这一刻之前，我跑下楼吃了一个鸡蛋和半个苹果。它还没消化，所以我感觉有点晕。我觉得我现在的状态很适合这一集。
I'm a little bit like, you know. Hungry? Yeah. Frazzled? Yeah. Do you just have eggs ready to go? You know, I hardboil an egg first thing. When I wake up in the morning, I put an egg in my hard boiler.
我有点，你知道。饿？是的。心烦意乱？是的。你只是准备好鸡蛋了吗？你知道，我早上醒来第一件事就是煮个鸡蛋。我把鸡蛋放进我的煮蛋器里。
Okay. And I just hadn't gotten back to it. So yeah, I had an egg ready to go. It's part of my. morning process. Things you need to know about Jennifer. Eggs, Rets to Go. That's right. Add it to your list. Today is Season 4, Episode 11, written by Steve Carell and directed by Paul Feig. Here is a summary. Give it to me. After Ryan excludes Michael from a corporate wilderness retreat, Michael heads out into the woods for his own survival adventure with nothing but the
好的。我只是还没来得及吃。所以是的，我准备好了一个鸡蛋。这是我早晨流程的一部分。关于珍妮弗你需要知道的事情。鸡蛋，随时准备好。没错。把它加到你的清单上。今天是第四季第11集，由史蒂夫·卡瑞尔编剧，保罗·费格导演。这是一个摘要。给我。在瑞安将迈克尔排除在公司荒野静修会之外后，迈克尔带着他背上的西装，独自前往树林进行他自己的生存冒险。德怀特暗中监视。回到办公室，吉姆试图彻底改变办公室生日派对系统，并了解到迈克尔的工作比看起来要难得多。哦，是的。对于那些真正关注的人，珍娜刚刚给了我们一个“德怀特”。我给了吗？你给了。我“克拉辛斯基”了它。来了一次克拉辛斯基。第一个速记事实，这一集是由我们自己的史蒂夫·卡瑞尔编写的。掌声，我们爱你史蒂夫，爱你。我联系了你，因为我想听听关于这一集灵感的来源。这是史蒂夫告诉我的，他说他和他的妻子南希喜欢这个叫《幸存者曼》的节目。所以史蒂夫提出了这一集的想法，因为他和南希是这个真实节目的忠实粉丝。
suit on his back. Dwight secretly keeps watch. Back at the office, Jim tries to revolutionize the office birthday party system and learns that Michael's job is a lot harder than it looks. Oh, yeah. And for those of you really paying attention, Jenna just gave us a DeWite. Did I? You did. I Krasinski'd it. Pulled a Krasinski. Fast fact number one, this episode was written by our very own Steve Karell. applause we love you steve love you i reached out because i wanted to hear a little bit about the inspiration for this episode here's what steve told me he said that he and his wife nancy loved this show called survivor man so steve pitched the idea for this episode because he and nancy were such
什么是《幸存者曼》？我从来没看过这个节目。我的意思是，我猜那个人得去某个地方生存。哦，安吉拉，你会很高兴的。什么？第二个速记事实是关于真实的《幸存者曼》节目。给我。这是一个加拿大电视节目，由现实生活中的生存专家和电影制作人莱斯·斯特劳德主演。在每一集中，他都会被扔在一个偏远的地方，他必须生存长达10天。他几乎没带食物、水或设备，除了他的摄像设备，因为他要自己拍摄自己。没有摄像组。但他会带杯子之类的吗？
fans of the real show what is survivor man i've never seen the show i mean i'm guessing the guy's got to go survive somewhere. Oh, Angela, you're going to be so happy. What? Fast fact number two is all about the real Survivor Man show. Give it to me. It was a Canadian TV show starring a real life survival expert and filmmaker, Les Stroud. In each episode, he would be dropped off in a remote location and he would have to survive up to 10 days. He brought little or no food, water, or equipment except for his camera equipment because he would film himself. There was no camera crew. But would he bring like a cup?
比如他怎么弄到水？没有，女士。没有设备。没有餐具。没错。哎呀。现在他们确实有安全预防措施。比如，你知道在这一集中德怀特是如何从远处观察迈克尔的吗？是的。
Like how does he get water? No lady. No equipment. No utensil. Correct. Aye, aye. Now they did have safety precautions. Like, you know in this episode how Dwight is kind of watching Michael from afar? Yeah.
有一个支持团队从远处监控这个人。以防他被野生动物袭击什么的。我们不会把他留在那里等死。我做那份工作不会很好。是观察那个人还是成为那个人？观察那个人。我不能。我就像，你知道，我必须发表我的看法。
There was a support team who monitored this guy from a distance. Just in case he got attacked by a wild animal or something. We're not going to leave him out there to die. I would not be good at that job. At watching the man or being the man? Watching the man. I can't. I'm like, you know, I've got to put in my two cents.
那会怎么运作？解释一下。嗯，比如，也许他开始去碰一丛灌木什么的。他不应该，你知道，去碰它。也许那是有毒的灌木。我不知道。我会开始说，嗯-嗯，嗯-嗯，嗯-嗯，嗯-嗯，嗯-嗯。嗯-嗯。
How would that work? Explain. Well, like, maybe he starts to go for a bush or something. He shouldn't, you know, be touching. Maybe it's the poisonous bush. I don't know. I'd start going like, uh-uh, uh-uh, uh-uh, uh-uh, uh-uh. Uh-uh.
或者我会假装是一只鸟，但就像会是，不！不。不是那个。你能看着别人挣扎吗？我在这方面会很糟糕。好吧，让我这么说吧。他被允许提前与当地专家团队一起侦察和研究这些区域。所以他会带着生存计划进去。他会知道当地的动物群和植物群。他会知道他应该吃什么或不应该吃什么。史蒂夫说的一件事是，他和南希注意到那个人总是做迈克尔做的那种事情。就像把一根棍子变成长矛，好像他要去刺杀一只动物。但他从来没有真正成功地杀死过一只动物。
Or I'd pretend to be a bird, but like it would be like, no! No. Not that one. Can you watch someone struggle? I'd be horrible at that. Well, let me say this. He was allowed to scout and study these areas ahead of time with a team of local experts. So he would go in with a survival plan. He would know the local fauna and flora. He would know what things he should eat or shouldn't eat. Something that, as Steve said, was that he and Nancy noticed that the guy was always doing things like Michael does. is like turning a stick into a spear, like he's going to go spear an animal. But he never actually succeeded in actually killing an animal.
所以史蒂夫和南希有一个理论，他只是真的不想杀死任何动物，因为他是一个非常好的人，因为他似乎从来没有真正抓到任何活的食物来吃。他是友好的幸存者曼。是的。第三个速记事实是地点细分。来了，感谢卡塔琳娜·里齐、悉尼·韦弗、杰森·贝里、索菲亚·斯皮尔和凯特·贝特里奇的粉丝提问。史蒂夫和雷恩在哪里拍摄森林场景？我猜是洛杉矶国家森林。
So Steve and Nancy had a theory that he just really didn't want to kill any animals because he was a really nice guy because he never seemed to actually catch any living food to eat. He was the friendly survivor man. Yeah. Fast fact number three is a location breakdown. Coming at you, thanks to fan question from Catalina Rizzy, Sydney Weaver, Jason Berey, Sophia Spear, and Kate Betteridge. Where did Stephen Rain film the forest scenes? I'm going to guess the Los Angeles National Forest.
嗯。我不这么认为。哦。我的意思是，除非洛杉矶国家森林在洛杉矶冠道公路的44英里标记处，因为那就是我们拍摄的地方。这些场景是在一个叫查尔顿平原的野餐地点拍摄的，我们花了一天时间拍摄了所有的森林场景，而那一天是，我能从你那里得到一个“肯塔百科”吗，安吉拉，因为肯塔百科给了我这个信息。肯塔，肯塔，肯塔百科！非常感谢。不客气。
Hmm. I don't think so. Oh. I mean, unless the Los Angeles National Forest is at the 44-mile marker on the Los Angeles Crest Highway, because that's where we shot. These scenes were filmed at a picnic site called Charlton Flats, and we spent one day shooting all of the forest scenes, and that day was, can I get a Kentapedia from you, Angela, because Kentapedia gave me this information. Kenta, Kenta, Kentapedia! Thank you so much. You're welcome.
2007年10月17日，星期三。那是一个非常具体的肯塔百科事实。我知道。所以那是十月，那是洛杉矶开始变冷的时候。所以迈克尔说白天很热，晚上很凉的一些东西，对于我们这里的洛杉矶来说其实非常准确。这就是这里的生活，伙计们。就像你离开时觉得热，然后在四个小时内就冻僵了。这确实是一个需要分层穿衣的城市。是的，绝对是一个分层穿衣的城市。是的。当然，
Wednesday, October 17, 2007. That's such a specific Kentapedia fact. I know. So it was October, and that is. is right when the chill starts to come over Los Angeles. So some of the stuff where Michael is like, it's so hot in the day and then it's cool at night, that's actually really accurate for us here in LA. That is life out here, guys. It's like you leave and you're like hot and then you're freezing in like four hours. It gets to layer. Yeah, it's a layering city for sure. Yeah. Of course,
我们的节目背景设定在宾夕法尼亚州的斯克兰顿。所以那时的斯克兰顿会比我们描绘的要冷得多。肯定的。我们没有把天气搞对，伙计们。我们搞错了。我们描绘了南加州一个美好的十月天。这就是我所有的了，女士。嗯，这一整集让我想起了克里德·布雷登，因为你知道，克里德是我的邻居。他喜欢这个节目《独自求生》。这就像一个生存主义节目，他让乔什和我迷上了它。当我观看这些节目时，我能想到的只有，A，我永远做不到。不是因为我可能不能打猎和钓鱼，而是因为我太怕冷了。
our show was set in Scranton, Pennsylvania. So it would have been much colder than we, depicted at that time in Scranton. For sure. We didn't get the weather right, guys. We got it wrong. We portrayed a nice October day in Southern California. That's all I got, lady. Well, this whole episode reminded me of Creed Braden, because you know, Creed's my neighbor. He loves this show alone. It's like a survivalist show, and he got Josh and I into it. And all I can think about when I watch these shows is, A, I would never make it. Not because I probably couldn't hunt and fish, but because I get too cold.
什么会让你受不了？我会太冷。我觉得是睡眠不足。每当我观看像《幸存者》或者人们进行极限露营或生存主义类型剧情的节目时，我总是想到他们没有得到充足的睡眠。我真的需要那种睡眠。我超级暴躁，而且当我睡眠不足时，我会出现身体症状。我会胃痛。
What would do you in? I would get too cold. I think the lack of sleep. Whenever I watch shows like Survivor or like people doing extreme camping or survivalist type storylines, I always think about how they're not getting a sound night's sleep. And I really need that sleep. I am super cranky, but also I get physical symptoms when I don't sleep enough. I get a stomachache.
我会头痛。我会变得非常晕。所以我认为睡眠不足会让我受不了。我几乎可以在任何地方睡觉。我想我会解决睡眠问题。但我会冻死。或者我会变得太冷，我会生气。然后我就放弃了。
I get a headache. I get like real loopy. So I think it would be the lack of sleep that would do me in. I can sleep pretty much anywhere. I think I would figure out sleep. But I would just freeze to death. Or I'd get so cold, I would get angry. And then I'd quit.
你就像，我离开这里了。这太冷了。我走了。去你们的吧。我的加热器在哪里？嗯，我的早餐起作用了，安吉。但我建议我们休息一下，回来谈谈我最喜欢的开场场景之一。你是说超级晒伤的托比吗？
You're like, I am out of here. This is too effing cold. I'm out. Screw you guys. Where's my heater? Well, my breakfast is kicking in, Ange. but I say we take a break and we'll come back to talk about one of my favorite opening scenes of an episode ever. Do you mean super sunburned Toby?
是的。超级开心的晒伤托比。好了，我们回来吧。我们回来了，各位。托比正在厨房里主持大局。我的意思是，他是我见过最兴奋的托比。我必须指出一点，当托比在主持大局时，对于我们的背景捕捉人员，在两秒钟时，你会看到那个在厨房里放了九季的红藤罐子。
Yes. Super happy sunburned Toby. All right, we'll be back. We are back and here it is, folks. Toby is holding court in the kitchen. I mean, he is the most lit up you will ever see Toby. I have to point out something while Toby is holding court for our best. Background catch people, at two seconds, you will see the jar of red vines that was in the kitchen for nine seasons.
是的。绝佳镜头。它就在菲利斯后面。我看着它，开始大笑。因为我觉得那些红藤会在世界末日中幸存下来，因为它们太硬而且恶心。哦，天哪。你根本吃不下它们。嗯-嗯。
Yes. Primo shot. It's right behind Phyllis. And I just looked at it and I started cracking up. Because I feel like those red vines would survive, you know, Armageddon because they were so schelact and gross. Oh, my gosh. You couldn't eat them. Mm-mm.
它们就像棍子一样。是的。我记得在第九季打开它们。它们和第一季一样。这很可怕。你知道吗？他们应该把那些带到树林里去。他们可以用它们来建造他们的避难所。
They were like sticks. Yeah. And I remember opening them in season nine. And they were the same as season one. It was scary. You know what? They should have taken those out into the woods. They could have used them to build their shelter.
我是红藤的忠实粉丝。我必须告诉你，当我去电影院时。我也是。红藤还是薄荷巧克力？噢，那太可爱了。是的。所以托比正在和帕姆、奥斯卡、菲利斯和梅雷迪斯聊天，谈论他参加的那个荒野静修会，
I'm a big Red Vines fan. I have to tell you when I go to the movies. Me too. Red Vines or Junior Mints? Aw, that's so cute. Yeah. So Toby is chatting with Pam, Oscar, Phyllis, and Meredith all about this wilderness retreat that he went
和瑞安以及其他一些分部经理一起。我们全神贯注地听他的每一句话。我们在笑。在这一系列采访片段中，你发现迈克尔没有被邀请参加荒野静修会。三个采访片段，人们说同样的话。菲利斯，托比，你。迈克尔没被邀请。
with Ryan and some of the other branch managers. We are hanging on his every word. We're laughing. And you come to find out in this series of talking heads that Michael was not invited on the wilderness retreat. Three talking heads where the people say the same thing. Phyllis, Toby, you. Michael wasn't invited.
他没被邀请。托比被邀请了。迈克尔没被邀请。当菲利斯说这句话时，她脸上的笑容太棒了。她很高兴迈克尔没被邀请。有一个被删减的美味采访片段。是瑞安在公司的办公室里。他说他有这个静修会的想法，但公司不会为此买单。
He wasn't invited. Toby was. Michael wasn't. And the smile on Phyllis's face when she says it is amazing. She's so delighted that Michael wasn't invited. There is a delicious talking head that was deleted. It is Ryan in his office at corporate. And he's saying how he had this idea for the retreat and corporate wouldn't pay for it.
他做了那个用第三人称说话的事情，他说，好吧，瑞安，解决它，明白了，让它与环境有关。他说让它成为一个绿色静修会。然后他们就会买单。然后他继续说，从来没有人为了帮助环境而做任何事情。如果有人告诉你他们有一个绿色倡议，那是一个骗局。哦，天哪。然后他说，现在他成了绿色奇才，你知道，绿色环保主义者，这会给办公室的女士们留下深刻印象。他故意把一个塑料水瓶放在一群女性旁边的回收箱里。
And he does that thing where he talks in third person where he's like, okay, Ryan, fix it, got it, make it about the environment. He says make it a green retreat. Then they pay for it. And then he goes on to say, no one ever does. anything for the environment just to help the environment. If someone tells you they have a green initiative, it's a scam. Oh my gosh. And then he's saying that now that he's like the green wonder kid, you know, the green environmentalist that it's going to impress the ladies of the office. And he purposefully like puts a plastic water bottle in the recycle bin by a group of women.
她们甚至没有理会他。这太搞笑了。嗯，我们有一个关于这个场景的粉丝提问，来自斯蒂芬妮·保林、凯瑟琳·洛扎、扎克·詹姆斯和安东尼·巴塔利亚。保罗看起来晒得好黑。他有特殊的晒伤化妆来让托比看起来像是在露营吗？是的。哦，是的，那是经过深思熟虑的。他们在他的脸上做了测试。他们拍了照片。他们决定是太多还是太少。我记得他们甚至做了他的前额，珍娜，就像他的发际线那里。是的。他们做得非常非常棒。它真的卖力了。它看起来很真实。嗯，迈克尔被这深深刺痛了。哦，他崩溃了。他在沸腾。他简直不敢相信托比被邀请参加这个而不是他。而且珍娜，他开始假设性地问人们是否会和他一起去露营。在被删减的场景中，他从帕姆开始。它被剪掉了。我希望它在里面。帕姆和吉姆显然有两条不同的策略来对付迈克尔。因为帕姆是，如果迈克尔问你一个假设性问题，你总是说不，因为他的假设可能会变成现实，你只要说不。然后他没法从你这里得到任何余地，所以他转向吉姆。
And they don't even acknowledge him. It's hilarious. Well, we had a fan question about this scene from Stephanie Paulin, Catherine Loza, Zach James, and Anthony Bataglia. Paul looks so tan. Does he have special sunburn makeup on to make it look like Toby has been camping? Yes. Oh yeah, that was very thought out. They did a test run on his face. They took pictures. They decided if it was too much or too little. And I remember they even did his forehead, Jenna, like where his hair line is. Yes. They did a great, great job. It really sell. it. It looks real. Well, Michael is so stung by this. Oh, he's devastated. He's seething. He just like can't believe that Toby was invited to this over him. And Jenna, he starts asking people hypothetically if they would go camping with him. In the deleted scenes, he starts with Pam. And it's cut out. And I wish it was in. Pam and Jim clearly have two different strategies with Michael. Because Pam is like, if Michael asked you a hypothetical, You always say no because his hypothetical could become an actually and you just say no. And then he doesn't make any leeway with you so he moves on to Jim.
但有一个很棒的场景，显然你和吉姆一起合作来避开迈克尔。为了引出你们即将听到的内容，帕姆在迈克尔的办公室里，他问她，假设性地，她会和他一起去露营吗？她说，不。所以他要转向吉姆。他说，吉姆在那里吗？她看了看他的桌子。吉姆不在那里。
But there is a great scene that clearly you and Jim kind of work together to avoid Michael. To set up what you're about to listen to you guys, Pam is in Michael's office and he asks her, hypothetically, would she go camping with him? She's like, no. So he's going to move on to Jim. He's like, is Jim there? She looks at his desk. Jim's not there.
但她知道迈克尔一说“你能让德怀特进来吗”，德怀特就会被派去追踪吉姆。所以她跑到休息室告诉吉姆躲起来。这太搞笑了。这是片段。吉姆在外面吗？不。你能让德怀特进来吗？是的。
But she knows the minute Michael's like, can you send in Dwight, Dwight's going to be put on the tracking of Jim. And so she runs to the break room to tell Jim to like hide. And it's just so hilarious. And here's the clip. Is Jim out there? No. Can you send Dwight in here? Yeah.
德怀特，迈克尔想在办公室见你。你想见我？嗯哼。我有一些非常私人的事情想讨论。你能去找到吉姆并让他进来吗，拜托？我这就去。迈克尔雇佣了德怀特来追踪你。你有多少时间？
Dwight, Michael wants to see you in his office. You wanted to see me? Mm-hmm. I have something very personal I would like to discuss. Would you go find Jim and send him in here, please? I'm on it. Michael has employed Dwight to track you down. How much time do you have?
吉姆，迈克尔的办公室。几分钟，多多少少。现在，吉姆。哦，天哪。我喜欢那个。迈克尔找了吉姆多少次？他和帕姆有这种秘密的事情，她说，德怀特在找你。
Jim, Michael's office. A couple minutes, give or take. Now, Jim. Oh my gosh. I love that. How many times was Michael looking for Jim? And him and Pam had this covert thing where she's like, Dwight's looking for you.
你有五分钟。这太好了。但是，你知道，德怀特确实找到了吉姆，对吧？所以现在吉姆在迈克尔的办公室里。迈克尔在问吉姆。假设性地，你想去露营吗？吉姆的策略和帕姆的完全不同。吉姆就像，总是说好，对吧？
You have five minutes. It's so good. But, you know, Dwight does find Jim, right? So now Jim is in Michael's office. And Michael is asking Jim. hypothetically, would you like to go camping? And Jim's strategy is totally different from Pam's. Jim's like, always say yes, right?
但然后找个借口。显然，吉姆的借口总是他在献血，我喜欢这个。我喜欢史蒂夫作为迈克尔的表演，当他说，一个人能献多少次血？是的。吉姆说，有限制吗？我不知道。
But then have an excuse. And apparently, Jim's excuse is always that he's donating blood, which I loved. I loved Steve's delivery as Michael when he says, how many times can a person give blood? Yeah. Jim says, is there a limit? I didn't know.
我记得，珍娜，约翰每次都笑场。史蒂夫作为迈克尔说，你的身体只有一定数量。是的。约翰会崩溃的。你记得吗？我记得，因为我在接待处做背景。我想在两分零九秒时，你可以看到约翰试图不笑场。此外，当迈克尔和吉姆谈论瑞安那个糟糕的露营旅行时，他显然
I remember, Jenna, John breaking every single time. that Steve, as Michael said, your body only has a certain amount. Yeah. That John would lose it. Do you remember that? I do, because I was in the background at reception. I think at two minutes, nine seconds, you can see John trying not to break. Also, when Michael is talking to Jim about Ryan's lame camping trip that he clearly
想去，他在嘲笑他们做了“斯莫尔斯”。他说，你好，我是断背山，你知道。这是这一刻，珍娜，我觉得迈克尔就像我的妈妈，因为我的妈妈永远记不住《断背山》这个名字，对吧？我的妈妈可能会认为它是“破碎山”。是的。
wanted to go on, he's kind of making fun that they did s'm s'm, Smoors. And he's like, hello, I'm broken mountain, you know. And this is this moment, Jenna, where I felt like Michael. was my mom because my mom would never get the name Brokeback Mountain, correct? My mom would probably think it was Broken Mountain. Yes.
我的妈妈总是差一个字。我的妈妈也是这样。我们会变成那样吗，安吉拉？我觉得我已经开始了。我觉得我们开始变成那样了。前几天我想说，比如“让我们FaceTime”，我说，“为什么我们不Facebook？”就是这样。
My mom is always one word off. My mom is the same way. Are we going to be like that, Angela? I think I already am. I feel like we're starting to turn into that. I went to say, like, let's FaceTime the other day, and I said, why don't we Facebook? There it is.
我知道。那是典型的妈妈大脑。它正在发生。嗯，然后迈克尔有一个采访片段，他解释说当他和简有卫星电视时，我猜也许他们因为钱的问题关掉了它。但是的，这是我们喜欢的事情。这是对“钱”的回应，对吧？
I know. That's classic mom brain right there. It's happening. Well, then Michael has a talking head where he explains that when he and Jan had satellite TV, I guess maybe they turned it off because of their money problems. But yes, this is the thing we love. This is the callback to money, right?
是的。他们现在预算紧张。奥斯卡给了他们一个预算。我还想指出，当我们看到《晚宴》那一集，看到迈克尔的新平板电视时，请记住上面没有卫星电视，正如这一集所确定的那样。那太棒了。
Yeah. They're on a budget now. Oscar has given them a budget. I also want to point out that when we get to the dinner party episode and we see Michael's new flat screen TV, just remember that has no satellite television on it, as established in this episode. That's great.
总之，他说他和简过去常看一个叫《幸存者曼》的节目，它是关于这个人在野外生存的故事，所以迈克尔要这样做，因为这是真正的荒野冒险。所以他告诉德怀特，我需要两样东西，一卷胶带和一把刀，我需要在30分钟内拿到。德怀特就像没问题。我稍微分析了一下旧办公室里的武器。
Anyway, he says that he and Jan used to watch a show called Survivor Man, and it's all about this guy who survives in the wild, and so Michael is going to do this, because this is real wilderness adventure. So he tells Dwight, I need two things, a roll of duct tape and a knife, and I need it in 30 minutes or less. And Dwight's like on it, no problem. I did a little bit of a breakdown of the weaponry in the old.
办公室？哦，太多了。德怀特在办公室里收集他藏起来的武器。女士，看看我的文档。你真的记录了它。有数字。它们被编号了。有多少个？好的。猜猜办公室里有多少武器？我不是在说他在车里有什么，因为我们知道他车后备箱里有东西。好的。只猜他藏在办公室里的。多少？八个。二十三个。什么？现在听着，办公室粉丝们，如果我弄错了，让我知道。但这是我追踪到的，我回去重看了谈判。所以，准备好了吗？在谈判中，贴在他桌子下面的是胡椒喷雾和飞镖。在他桌子的抽屉里是双节棍，一个看起来像警棍的东西。
office? Oh, there's so much. Dwight goes around the office collecting weapons that he's hidden. Lady, look at my documentation. You really did document it. There's numbers. They're numbered. How many are there? Okay. Guess how many weapons are in the office? I'm not talking about what he has in his car, because we know he has stuff in the trunk of his car. Okay. Just guess what he has stashed in the office. How many? Eight. Twenty-three. What? Now listen, office fans, if I got it wrong, let me know. But this is what I tracked, and I went back and rewatch the negotiation. So, ready? In the negotiation, taped underneath his desk are pepper spray and throwing stars. In his desk drawer are Nunchucks, a Billy Club looking thing.
听着，我的武器专家们，如果我弄错了一些名字，只是，你知道，你们会让我知道的。然后还有手铐、电击枪、另一个飞镖、看起来像鞭子的东西、指虎和一个回旋镖。那只是在谈判中。在这一集中，梅雷迪斯的桌子下面，他拿出一套八种不同类型的刀。两个干草叉匕首一样的东西在饮水机后面。凯文桌子旁的文件柜里有一把巨大的刀。斯坦利和菲利斯桌子上面的天花板里有一把武士刀。最后，他在男洗手间里有吹箭，就像在马桶后面。
And listen, my weapons experts, if I get some of these names wrong, just, you know, you'll let me know. then there's also handcuffs, a taser, another throwing star, what looks like to be a whip, brass knuckles, and a boomerang. That's just in the negotiation. And in this episode, under Meredith's desk are like he rolls out a set of like eight different types of knives. Two pitchfork dagger-looking things are behind the water cooler. There's a giant knife in the file cabinets by Kevin's desk. There's a samurai sword in the ceiling over Stanley and and Phyllis's desk. And then finally, he has blow darts in the men's restroom, like in the back of the toilet.
你管马桶后面那个东西叫什么？水箱。水箱。是的。所以当我把它们加在一起时，伙计们，我数了办公室里有23件武器。这真是一个武器动物园。一个武器动物园，德怀特。我不知道那些干草叉匕首一样的东西叫什么，我相信你们会让我知道的。
What do you call the back of the toilet thing? The tank. The tank. Yes. So when I added them all up, you guys, I counted 23 weapons in the office. It's quite a menagerie of weaponry. A monotery of weapons, Dwight. And I don't know what those pitchfork dagger thingies are called, and I'm sure you guys will let me know.
但这就是它们在我看来像的样子。我也不知道那些是什么。它们看起来非常适合烤棉花糖。尽管我明白它们是武器，但它看起来像一个非常棒的三重棉花糖烤架。嗯，是的。不管什么原因，我对吹箭筒非常感兴趣。哦，好的。
but that's what they look like to me. I don't know what those were either. They seemed like they would be really good for roasting marshmallows. Even though I understand they're a weapon, it seemed like a really great triple marshmallow roaster. Mm, yeah. I got really interested for whatever reason in the blowdart gun. Oh, okay.
所以猜猜我为你准备了什么？你对吹箭筒有深入研究吗？我当然有。哦，女士，女士，给我。在这里。据我所知，吹箭似乎是在古代发明的，可能是在东南亚。它们最初是竹管，射出种子和粘土颗粒。好的。然后最终升级为毒镖。现在，安吉拉，你可能会觉得这很有趣，因为人们认为正是印度尼西亚商人把吹箭筒带到了日本、南印度、马达加斯加，它们也出现在南美洲、中美洲和美国东部。Wadu！那是印度尼西亚语，意思是“哦，天哪”。
So guess what I have for you. Do you have a deep dive on blow dart guns? I sure do. Oh, lady, lady, give it to me. Here it is. From what I could find, the blow dart seems to have been invented in ancient times and probably in Southeast Asia. They started as bamboo tubes that shot out seeds and clay pellets. Okay. And then eventually graduated to poison darts. Now, Angela, you might find this interesting because it is believed that it was Indonesian traders that took the blowgun to Japan, South India, Madaghan. Gascar, and they also popped up in South America, Middle America, and the eastern United States. Wadu! That's Indonesian for, oh my goodness.
就是这样。吹箭筒主要用于狩猎，而不是战斗。我觉得在电影里，我们总是看到它们在战斗场景中使用，对吧？嗯哼。但它们实际上是一种狩猎装置。北美切罗基人以使用它们狩猎兔子和其他小动物而闻名，吹箭筒今天仍在使用。甚至还有运动吹箭比赛，安吉拉，
There we go. Dark guns were primarily used for hunting, not combat. I feel like in movies, we always see them used in combat scenes, right? Mm-hmm. But they were actually a hunting device. The North American Cherkies were known for using them to hunt rabbit and other small creatures, and blowguns are still used today. There are even sport blowgun competitions, Angela,
一些团体正试图让它成为奥运会项目。我会看那个。是的。吹箭项目？我会在那里。女士，我们可以去参加吹箭比赛吗？我很着迷。我们可以去找一位吹箭大师，接受如何吹箭的训练吗？
and some groups are trying to make it an Olympic event. I would watch that. Yeah. The blowdart event? I'm there. Lady, can we go to a blow dart competition? I'm fascinated. Can we go to a blow dart master and get trained on how to blow dart?
我准备好了一切。研究完吹箭后，我就想，放马过来吧。放马过来吧。我告诉你，我的即兴表演团队之一，我们有一个演员有时会霸占舞台，就是不离开舞台，接管每一个场景。所以我们一群人开始对他进行即兴吹箭。我们只是像，他得晕倒。
I'm up for all of it. After researching the blow dart, I'm like, bring it on. Bring it on. I'll tell you what, one of my improv teams, we had a player who would sometimes hog the stage and just not leave the stage and take over every scene. So a bunch of us started improv blow darting him. We just go like, he'd have to pass out.
我们只是开始在场景中对他吹箭。这非常有趣。他是你们班的迈克尔。是的。嗯，伙计们，迈克尔准备好了。他走出办公室，告诉帕姆他和德怀特要离开。德怀特稍后会回来。迈克尔明天会请一天个人假，也许接下来的两天也是。
We'd just start blow darting him in scenes. That is very funny. He was the Michael of your class. Yeah. Well, guys, Michael is ready to go. He comes out of his office and he tells Pam that he and Dwight are leaving. Dwight will return later. And Michael will be taking a personal day tomorrow and perhaps for the next two days.
帕姆说，你想让我问你去哪里吗？是的。他说，不。然后他还是告诉了她。当然。我注意到德怀特在整个演讲过程中都站在迈克尔身后。他拿着四样东西。他拿着一个摄像机。
And Pam is like, do you want me to ask you where you're going? Yeah. And he says, no. And then he tells her anyway. Of course. I noticed Dwight is standing behind Michael this whole speech. He is holding four things. He is holding a camera.
嗯哼。就是我们用来制作迈克尔道歉视频的那个摄像机。嗯哼。一卷胶带。嗯哼。其中一把巨大的刀。嗯哼。还有一袋什么？
Mm-hmm. The same camera that we used to make Michael's apology video. Mm-hmm. A roll of duct tape. Mm-hmm. One of the giant knives. Mm-hmm. And a bag of what?
那是什么？那是什么？我放大了。我拍了一张照片。我看不出来。起初，我想，是花生吗？不可能是花生。它也太满了。
What is it? What is it? I zoomed in. I took a picture of it. I can't tell. At first, I was like, is it peanuts? There's no way it's peanuts. It's also so full.
它看起来像你喂仓鼠的颗粒。这就是它看起来的样子。对我来说。它看起来像某种动物饲料。我不知道。就像他要撒在周围来吸引动物？嗯，我们从来没见他吃过它。我们从来没见他用过袋子里的东西。他用了其他三样东西。我不知道。我们只看到他拿着那个问号袋子。没错。在这一幕中，我也喜欢迈克尔宣布当他回来时，他将成为一个完全改变的人。然后吉姆说，那太棒了。啊，太好了。德怀特，当然，有这个采访片段，非常有趣，他说他不相信迈克尔能活下来。
It looks like the pellets you feed your hamster. That's what it looks like. to me. It looks like some sort of animal kibble. I don't know. Like he's going to sprinkle around to attract animals? Well, we never see him eat it. We never see him use what's in the bag. He uses the other three things. I don't know. We see him only hold the bag of question mark. That's right. Also in this scene, I love that Michael announces that when he comes back, he is going to be a completely changed human being. And then Jim says, that would be great. Ah, so good. Dwight, of course, has this talking head, which is really funny where he's like, no, he doesn't believe Michael would survive
看起来就像你喂仓鼠吃的颗粒饲料。对我来说就是那样。看起来像某种动物干粮。我不知道。就像他要撒在周围来吸引动物一样？好吧，我们从没见过他吃。我们从没见过他用袋子里的东西。他用了另外三样东西。我不知道。我们只看到他拿着那个问号袋子。没错。另外在这一幕里，我喜欢迈克尔宣布他回来时会变成一个彻底改变的人。然后吉姆说，那太棒了。啊，太好了。当然，德怀特有这个采访镜头，真的很有趣，他说，不，他不相信迈克尔能活下来
in the wilderness, super matter of fact. But lady, I have to point out something at five minutes, 19 seconds. What is it? Why are Michael and Dwight in a 2006 or 2007, give or take, PT Cruiser? I think we have a car switch. Is this an extension of Michael's money stuff where he said they traded in both their cars for that Porsche? And did they get rid of the Porsche? And now he has a PT Cruiser? Oh my gosh. We need someone to figure this out.
在荒野中，非常一本正经。但是女士，我必须指出五分十九秒的一个地方。是什么？为什么迈克尔和德怀特开着一辆大约2006年或2007年的PT漫步者？我想我们换车了。这是迈克尔金钱问题的一个延伸吗？他说他们把两辆车都换成了那辆保时捷？他们把保时捷卖了吗？现在他有一辆PT漫步者？天哪。我们需要有人弄清楚这件事。
We do. And I looked up the PT cruiser. This is around the 2007 make with the red interior. I googled it. Why is Michael having a Chrysler PT cruiser? I need to know why. Who could we ask? I don't know.
确实。我查了一下PT漫步者。这是2007年左右的款式，有红色内饰。我谷歌了一下。为什么迈克尔会有克莱斯勒PT漫步者？我需要知道为什么。我们可以问谁？我不知道。
Guys, this is one of those moments where you can see so clearly that we are not the experts of the office. Perhaps there is a really obvious answer for this. Like, remember when I declared that Pam had never used the shredder and then several episodes later, she clearly uses the shredder and take your daughter to work day? It is very possible that we missed why he's driving a PT cruiser. Someone tell us. Let us know. This is going to keep me up at night and you know how I do with no sleep. Let her know.
伙计们，这是那种你能清楚地看出我们不是《办公室》专家的时刻之一。也许对此有一个非常明显的答案。就像记得我曾宣称帕姆从未使用过碎纸机，结果几集之后，她在“带女儿上班日”里明显使用了碎纸机吗？很有可能我们错过了他开PT漫步者的原因。有人告诉我们吧。让我们知道。这会让我彻夜难眠，而且你知道我睡眠不足时是什么样子。让她知道。
And while they're in this PT cruiser, Angela, Michael is explaining to the camera what's happening. We are to assume that Michael is being driven to the forest by a serial killer who's going to leave him for dead, but Michael is going to survive. The overkill killer, as Dwight calls himself. Yes. He says, if I were your serial killer, you would never survive. Mm-mm. I have a fan question from Elizabeth Congdon and Matthew Lister. In this scene in the car, Dwight takes off his shoe and hits Michael in the head.
当他们在PT漫步者里时，安吉拉，迈克尔正在向摄像机解释发生了什么。我们应该假设迈克尔正被一个连环杀手开车带到森林里，要把他丢在那里等死，但迈克尔会活下来。正如德怀特自称的那样，是“过度杀手”。是的。他说，如果我是你的连环杀手，你永远也活不下来。嗯嗯。我有一个来自伊丽莎白·康登和马修·利斯特的粉丝提问。在车里的这一幕中，德怀特脱下鞋子打了迈克尔的头。
Was the shoe hit planned or improvised? And Joey Carr would like to know, was that an actual shoe? Or did Phil Shea have to make a shoe out of rubber or some other soft material that wouldn't hurt Steve? I asked Steve about this. Yeah. First of all, it was planned. It was in the script. It was not improv.
鞋子打人是计划好的还是即兴发挥的？乔伊·卡尔想知道，那是真的鞋子吗？还是菲尔·谢不得不制作了一双橡胶或其他软材料做的鞋子，以免伤到史蒂夫？我问过史蒂夫这件事。是的。首先，这是计划好的。剧本里写了。不是即兴发挥。
of Steve believes it was a real shoe. He is not sure. I zoomed in on it. It looked like a real shoe. Steve said maybe the reason he can't remember is because it was a real shoe. And so he's going with real shoe. I zoomed in on it too, Jenna. Not only do I think it was a real shoe, I actually think it's Dwight's shoe.
史蒂夫认为那是真的鞋子。他不确定。我放大了看。看起来像真的鞋子。史蒂夫说也许他记不清的原因是因为它就是真的鞋子。所以他认为是真的鞋子。我也放大了看，珍娜。我不仅认为那是真的鞋子，我实际上认为那是德怀特的鞋子。
I think it came off Rain's foot. It looks exactly like the shoes he wore. Yes. And I can't imagine that Phil Shea was able to make a replica foam shoe. That was a real shoe. Back in the office, there's some drama. I guess Jim has been put in charge of things because of Michael's absence, and Angela goes up to Jim to talk about ordering a cake for Creed's birthday. Well, she lets him know it's birthday month.
我认为它是从雷恩的脚上脱下来的。它看起来和他穿的鞋子一模一样。是的。而且我无法想象菲尔·谢能制作出一双泡沫仿制品。那是一双真的鞋子。回到办公室，有一些戏剧性的事情。我想因为迈克尔不在，吉姆负责了事务，安吉拉去找吉姆谈为克里德的生日订蛋糕的事。好吧，她让他知道现在是生日月。
And you guys, we all have birthday month, right? Our birthday month in my family is May. All three kids are born in May. my mother-in-law's born in May. Two of my sisters are born in May. We call it Birthday Palooza. Jenna, what's your birthday month? Our birthday month was March when I was growing up.
你们知道吗，我们都有生日月，对吧？我们家人的生日月是五月。三个孩子都是五月出生的。我婆婆是五月出生的。我的两个姐妹也是五月出生的。我们称之为“生日狂欢”。珍娜，你的生日月是什么时候？我成长过程中，我们的生日月是三月。
Me, my sister, and my mom are all born in March. So we had three birthdays in one month. I'm telling you, every family has one. And at Dundra Mifflin, this is birthday month. Creed's is today. Oscars is a week after next. Meredith is at the end of the month. We also find out later in this episode from Creed,
我和我姐姐，还有我妈妈都是三月出生的。所以我们在一个月里有三个生日。我告诉你，每个家庭都有一个。在邓德 Mifflin，这是生日月。克里德的是今天。奥斯卡的在下下周。梅雷迪思的在月底。我们后来在这一集中从克里德那里得知，
that Jim's was three weeks ago, and there's a series of talking heads about birthdays. Angela says, you know what? If this is birthday month, jog back nine months. You know what that was? Valentine's Day. And then she tells everyone, stagger your sin. Stagger your sin, so we don't have birthday month. And Jenna, Kelly, has a talking head about the birthdays.
吉姆的是三周前，关于生日有一系列的采访片段。安吉拉说，你知道吗？如果这是生日月，往回推九个月。你知道那是什么吗？情人节。然后她告诉大家，错开你们的罪孽。错开你们的罪孽，这样我们就不会有生日月了。珍娜，凯利有一个关于生日的采访片段。
And I am just going to show you a screen grab because I really need. need it to just be a surprise. I want you to read. I put the subtitles on last night. I want you to read what Kelly says about Pam, because this is a little bit a Kelly shade. Oh my gosh. Read out loud what Kelly says about you. Pam lies about her age. That's amazing. There's a great runner of talking heads that were deleted, and that's part of Kelly Kapoor's. Well, I'll tell you something. In real life, I am five years older than John Krasinski. Scandalous. I know.
我只是要给你们看一张截图，因为我真的需要。需要它成为一个惊喜。我想要你读一下。我昨晚加上了字幕。我想要你读一下凯利关于帕姆说了什么，因为这有点凯利的讽刺。天哪。大声读出凯利关于你说了什么。帕姆谎报年龄。太神奇了。有一系列很棒的被删减的采访片段，那是凯利·卡普尔的一部分。好吧，我告诉你一件事。在现实生活中，我比约翰·卡拉辛斯基大五岁。丑闻。我知道。
But on the show, our characters were meant to be the same age. I couldn't tell. So I think they made Jim a little bit older than John, and they made Pam a little younger than me. You met in the middle. Well, I want to point out two things at six minutes, five seconds during this whole conversation between Angela and Jim, which, by the way, this episode was the most Jim and Angela have interacted so far to date. This is the most they've ever had to speak to each other. Huge Janjala storyline.
但在剧中，我们的角色被设定为同龄。我看不出来。所以我认为他们让吉姆比约翰稍微大一点，让帕姆比我稍微年轻一点。你们折中了。好吧，我想指出六分五秒时的两件事，在安吉拉和吉姆的整个对话期间，顺便说一句，这一集是迄今为止吉姆和安吉拉互动最多的一集。这是他们有史以来交流最多的一次。巨大的“Janjala”故事情节。
Janjala storyline. At six minutes, five seconds, Jenna, this is the return of the puffy elbow sweater. Oh, it's so unattractive. I'm sorry, lady. Your face, your bangs, your skin is glowing. You look gorgeous. This top is a tragedy. Why did they buy it in two colors?
“Janjala”故事情节。在六分五秒，珍娜，这是泡泡袖毛衣的回归。哦，太难看了。抱歉，女士。你的脸，你的刘海，你的皮肤在发光。你看上去很美。这件上衣是个悲剧。为什么他们买了两种颜色？
Remember, I wore it in the beige version of Launch Party. Yeah. Well, it's back. Now it's in maroon, so we've got that going. But my plant at reception, over Jim's shoulder, we see the plant at front reception. It is a blooming plant. Oh. Whoa. What? It is a pink antherum. Huh. Blooming. Uh-huh. Blooming plant at front reception. Lady, Jim has a big idea that is not going to go over well. It is not. It pisses literally everyone off.
记得我在“发布会”那集穿了米色版本吗。是的。好吧，它回来了。现在是栗色的，所以我们有这个。但是前台的植物，在吉姆的肩膀后面，我们看到了前台的植物。那是一株开花的植物。哦。哇。什么？那是一株粉红色的红掌。嗯。开花。嗯哼。前台的开花植物。女士，吉姆有一个大主意，不会有好结果的。确实不会。它真的惹恼了所有人。
Jim suggests that they just do one big party rather than several parties over the course of the month. Angela doesn't like it. No one's going to like this idea. Yeah. You know, I wouldn't have liked that. Growing up in my family, I don't want to share a birthday with my sister or with my mom. In my house, our tradition was that you got to pick your cake and you got to pick your dinner on your birthday. And my sister and I like different dinners and different cakes. And it's very similar to what's going to happen in the office. Everybody wants their own little thing. Mm-hmm. Next up, we have a gym talking head that has a wonderful montage that goes along with it of birthday surprises. Angela, we got more mail about this talking head than any talking head I think we've ever had.
吉姆建议他们只办一个大型派对，而不是在整个月里办好几个派对。安吉拉不喜欢。没有人会喜欢这个主意。是的。你知道，我不会喜欢的。在我家成长过程中，我不想和我的姐妹或妈妈共用一个生日。在我们家，我们的传统是生日那天你可以选蛋糕，可以选晚餐。我和我姐姐喜欢不同的晚餐和不同的蛋糕。这和办公室里将要发生的事情非常相似。每个人都想要自己的小东西。嗯哼。接下来，我们有一个吉姆的采访片段，伴随着一段精彩的生日惊喜蒙太奇。安吉拉，我们收到的关于这个采访片段的邮件比我们有史以来收到的任何采访片段都要多。
Is it about all the different birthday parties? No. Well, I took a picture because in this montage of all the different birthday parties, there is a a moment where we are all just flat out laughing. Oh, yeah. We've completely broken character, and it's when Brian takes the blow-up doll and is beating Rain over the head with it. They improvised that. That was just them being idiots. A lot of people wanted to know how much were we actually laughing in all of these clips. Here, I screen grabbed a moment, Jenna, where you can just see me and Ed Helms and Oscar just cracking up. Look at that. That is not Angela Martin. That is
是关于所有不同的生日派对吗？不。好吧，我拍了一张照片，因为在这个不同生日派对的蒙太奇中，有一个时刻我们都在放声大笑。哦，是的。我们完全打破了角色，那是布莱恩拿着充气娃娃打雷恩的头的时候。他们是即兴发挥的。那只是他们表现得像白痴。很多人想知道在所有这些片段中我们实际上笑了多少。这里，我截取了一个时刻，珍娜，你可以看到我和艾德·赫尔姆斯还有奥斯卡都在大笑。看那个。那不是安吉拉·马丁。那是
amazing. I will put that screen grab in stories. We had a lot of people write in to point out that Jim says there are 13 people in the office, but shouldn't there be 14? I wrote it out. There's 14, but Keith Nichols said, is Jim leaving out Toby on purpose just like Michael would? Oh, subconsciously. Right? Maybe. Yes, it's 14 with Toby, 13 without. Oh. You know what is interesting to me is that it's clear that Pam knows that this is a horrible idea. She knows it's a disaster. She goes up to Jim and is like, you think this is a good idea? And he's like, I think it's a great one.
太棒了。我会把那张截图发到故事里。我们有很多人写信指出吉姆说办公室里有13个人，但不应该是14个吗？我写下来了。有14个，但基思·尼科尔斯说，吉姆是不是像迈克尔一样故意把托比排除在外了？哦，潜意识里。对吧？也许。是的，算上托比是14个，不算的话是13个。哦。你知道什么对我来说很有趣吗，很明显帕姆知道这是一个糟糕的主意。她知道这是一场灾难。她走到吉姆面前说，你觉得这是个好主意吗？他说，我觉得这是个好主意。
And she just kind of smiles like, no gay. Why doesn't Pam say anything? I don't know why she doesn't. But Jim does seem a little immovable here, right? He seems a little convinced that he has a great idea. And I think she's like, okay. Let's play it out. Let's see how this goes, buddy.
她只是笑了笑，好像在说，没门。为什么帕姆什么都不说？我不知道她为什么不说。但吉姆在这里看起来有点不可动摇，对吧？他似乎有点确信他有一个好主意。我想她心想，好吧。让我们看看会发生什么。让我们看看这会怎么发展，伙计。
But she knows how it's going to go. Maybe she just needs to let him figure it out. He has to find his own way. I guess so. Guys, at this point, Dwight and Michael have arrived in the woods. Michael is blindfolded and he has asked Dwight to lead him into the wilderness. Do you notice how Dwight purposely takes Michael through a bunch of weeds rather than walk him on the clear path? Yeah.
但她知道会怎么发展。也许她只是需要让他自己去弄明白。他必须找到自己的路。我想是这样。伙计们，此时，德怀特和迈克尔已经到达了树林。迈克尔被蒙住了眼睛，他要求德怀特带他进入荒野。你注意到德怀特是如何故意带迈克尔穿过一堆杂草，而不是走在清晰的小路上吗？是的。
He's like, don't worry, just some bushes and some thickets when he clearly could have walked around them. Before removing his blindfold, Dwight also insists on spinning Michael around, which I loved. There are so many deleted scenes of them in the woods. Jenna, what these men went through that week. I mean, they wrestle each other to the ground. There's just so many scenes. Like Dwight is doing bird calls. He's hiding.
他说，别担心，只是一些灌木丛和荆棘，而他明明可以绕过它们。在摘下眼罩之前，德怀特还坚持要让迈克尔转圈，我很喜欢这个。关于他们在树林里的删减片段太多了。珍娜，这些男人那周经历了什么。我的意思是，他们把对方摔倒在地。有太多的场景了。比如德怀特在模仿鸟叫。他在躲藏。
Michael is exploring a ravine saying, absolute nonsense. He's saying that like, yeah, this ravine was formed when the icebergs, like he's saying all this crazy stuff. And I kept thinking as I watched all this extra footage, what does Michael do with this footage? What does he do with all this? Who ever sees the stuff? I don't know. I think that all the time when I see people doing things like videotaping a fireworks display. You're going to watch that later? I know. You're going to watch that seven-minute video of the fireworks.
迈克尔在探索峡谷，说着绝对的废话。他说，是的，这个峡谷是冰山形成的，就像他在说所有这些疯狂的事情。我一边看这些额外的镜头一边想，迈克尔用这些镜头做什么？他用这些做什么？谁会看这些东西？我不知道。我每次看到人们做像录制烟花表演这样的事情时，我都会一直这么想。你以后会看那个吗？我知道。你会看那个七分钟的烟花视频。
And by the way, while the fireworks are going off, you want to watch your phone screen? I don't get it. Yeah. No. So Dwight has left Michael on his own. Of course, we know he's secretly watching him. And Michael has decided it's getting hot. And he takes his knife.
顺便说一句，当烟花燃放时，你想看你的手机屏幕吗？我不明白。是的。不。所以德怀特把迈克尔独自留下了。当然，我们知道他在暗中监视他。迈克尔决定天气变热了。他拿出他的刀。
I was so worried about his leg the whole time, by the way, that he was going to, like, sever his leg. Me too. He cuts his pants into shorts. Mm-hmm. He then decides to. to make a hat out of the extra material. His jacket can be a backpack. He's just saying the craziest things.
顺便说一句，我一直很担心他的腿，他会，比如，切断他的腿。我也是。他把裤子剪成了短裤。嗯哼。然后他决定用多余的材料做一顶帽子。他的夹克可以当背包。他只是在说最疯狂的事情。
And he has destroyed his pants. We got a lot of mail about that scene from Jordan Y, Mary Triggs, and Colby Shannon. They wanted to know was Steve really cutting his pants? Was the costume rigged in some way? I reached out to Steve because like you, Angela, I was very nervous. It looked very real. Yeah. And Steve said the costume was not rigged.
他毁了他的裤子。我们收到了很多关于那个场景的邮件，来自乔丹·Y、玛丽·特里格斯和科尔比·香农。他们想知道史蒂夫是真的在剪裤子吗？服装有什么机关吗？我联系了史蒂夫，因为和你一样，安吉拉，我非常紧张。看起来非常真实。是的。史蒂夫说服装没有机关。
He cut his pants with a real nice. Shut up! He said it was, in hindsight, it was a truly stupid thing to do. He kind of can't believe that he did it. I cannot believe this. We would have a freaking safety meeting for a lit candle. And now Steve is cutting his pants open in the middle of nowhere, by the way. If he did cut his leg, they were far from anything.
他用一把真刀剪了他的裤子。闭嘴！他说，事后看来，这是一件非常愚蠢的事情。他简直不敢相信他做了这件事。我简直不敢相信。我们甚至会为一支点燃的蜡烛开安全会议。而现在史蒂夫在荒郊野外剪开他的裤子，顺便说一句。如果他真的割伤了他的腿，他们离任何地方都很远。
Yeah. Steve really likes this moment, though. He said it makes them laugh because in the movie Castaway, Tom Hanks does this and that's kind of where he got the idea. But Tom Hanks does it after he's been on the deserted island for like two years. Yeah. And Michael does it after 35 minutes. Listen, lady, I think we should take a break. And when we come back, we're going to discuss some cake drama. I can't wait. I still can't believe he cut his own pants with that knife. I know. He specifically told me he did not use stunt legs. Oh, my God. Stunt legs or a stunt knife.
是的。不过史蒂夫真的很喜欢这个时刻。他说这让他们发笑，因为在电影《荒岛余生》中，汤姆·汉克斯就是这么做的，这就是他灵感的来源。但汤姆·汉克斯是在荒岛上待了大约两年后才这么做的。是的。而迈克尔是在35分钟后就这么做了。听着，女士，我想我们应该休息一下。回来后，我们将讨论一些蛋糕的戏剧性事件。我等不及了。我仍然不敢相信他用那把刀剪了自己的裤子。我知道。他专门告诉我他没有用替身腿。哦，天哪。替身腿或替身刀。
No stunt legs, no stunt knife. And no tear away clothes. That was all real. We are back and we have Cake Wars. Cake Wars at Dundermifflin. And not the fun kind where they decorate a great cake. Exactly. No.
没有替身腿，没有替身刀。也没有撕拉式衣服。那都是真的。我们回来了，我们有“蛋糕大战”。邓德 Mifflin的蛋糕大战。不是那种他们装饰一个很棒蛋糕的有趣的那种。完全不是。不。
everyone wants their own cake. Meredith is like, listen, I want devil's food cake. Jim's like, no problem. And then this ticks off Creed. Creed is like, it is my actual birthday. Like Meredith doesn't get to pick the cake. I don't like devil's food cake. I want peach pie. I absolutely love Jim and Creed's scene together. It's done in this very different style. It looks totally different from any other scene. It's uptight and close. Creed's super intense. It reminds me of like an Aaron Sorkin kind of moment where it's like ratat-tat-tat. dialogue back and forth. And he's like, listen, tell Angelette's for Creed. She'll know what it means. Can I say something controversial? What? You don't like Aaron Sorkin? I love Aaron Sorkin. I don't like peach pie. Oh. I don't like any kind of peach in a dessert. Oh. I love every other
每个人都想要自己的蛋糕。梅雷迪思说，听着，我想要恶魔蛋糕。吉姆说，没问题。然后这惹恼了克里德。克里德说，这真的是我的生日。梅雷迪思不能选蛋糕。我不喜欢恶魔蛋糕。我想要桃子派。我绝对喜欢吉姆和克里德在一起的场景。它是以这种非常不同的风格完成的。它看起来和任何其他场景完全不同。它紧张且亲密。克里德超级强烈。这让我想起像艾伦·索金那样的时刻，就像机关枪一样的对话。他说，听着，告诉安吉拉这是给克里德的。她会知道这意味着什么。我可以发表一些有争议的言论吗？什么？你不喜欢艾伦·索金？我喜欢艾伦·索金。我不喜欢桃子派。哦。我不喜欢甜点里的任何桃子。哦。我喜欢其他所有的
cobbler. I love berry cobbler. Apples. Whatever you want to throw in there, no peaches for me. I don't know what it is. If it's a peach, I want it to stay. a peach and I want to eat it as a peach. I'm not interested in it being desertified. What is that? I don't know. I don't know what that is. I mean, do you like, like, do they do peach jam? I don't want peach as a jam. Okay. I love how strongly you feel about it. I have very Angela Martin-esque feelings about how peaches are to be prepared. Can I share something with you? What? Okay, Jenna, this is a snarky moment. for me. I'm going to share it with you and everyone listening. Okay, my whole entire life, I'm a summer birthday. So when I was growing up, they would like have the birthday celebration of whoever at school, it was their birthday, right? There'd be like some kind of birthday snack or you'd wear a birthday crown or whatever it was that your classroom did, right? Yeah. I never got one because I had a summer birthday. And guess what, guys, if you grew up in the 70s and 80s, there was no like,
脆皮甜点。我喜欢浆果脆皮甜点。苹果。无论你想放什么进去，不要给我桃子。我不知道为什么。如果它是桃子，我希望它保持桃子的样子，我想把它当作桃子吃。我对它变成甜点不感兴趣。那是什么？我不知道。我不知道那是什么。我的意思是，你喜欢，比如，他们做桃子果酱吗？我不想要桃子果酱。好吧。我喜欢你对它的强烈感觉。我对桃子应该如何准备有非常安吉拉·马丁式的感觉。我可以和你分享一件事吗？什么？好吧，珍娜，这是一个讽刺的时刻。对我来说。我要和你以及所有听众分享。好吧，我的一生，我是夏季生日。所以当我成长过程中，他们会在学校里为生日是那天的人举办生日庆祝活动，对吧？会有某种生日零食，或者你会戴上生日皇冠什么的，无论你的教室做什么，对吧？是的。我从来没有得到过，因为我是夏季生日。而且猜猜怎么着，伙计们，如果你是在70年代和80年代长大的，根本没有，
this is for all the summer birthday celebration. They didn't give a crap. You had a summer birthday. You didn't get any kind of celebration at school. Nowadays, if you have a summer birthday, they do a little thing for the kids with the summer birthdays. Not when I was growing up. Cut to our time on the office. Nine years, Jenna.
这是给所有夏季生日庆祝的。他们根本不在乎。你是夏季生日。你在学校里得不到任何庆祝。现在，如果你是夏季生日，他们会为夏季生日的孩子做点小事。我成长的时候可没有。切到我们在办公室的时间。九年，珍娜。
Nine years, I watched all of you guys get a birthday cake. Oh, no. I watched the whole entire cast and crew gather around and clap and sing, happy birthday and take pictures. And Peter and Vartan would make a special cake for the birthday person. nine years. Yep. We never shot the office in June,
九年，我看着你们所有人得到生日蛋糕。哦，不。我看着整个剧组和工作人员聚在一起鼓掌、唱生日快乐歌并拍照。彼得和瓦尔坦会为生日的人做一个特别的蛋糕。九年。是的。我们从来没有在六月拍摄过办公室，
did we, Angela? Never shot the office in June. Guess who never got the office birthday cake? Oh, no. Me. Oh, God. I never got it. Oh, no.
对吧，安吉拉？从来没有在六月拍摄过办公室。猜猜谁从来没有得到过办公室生日蛋糕？哦，不。我。哦，天哪。我从来没有得到过。哦，不。
I never got it. I remember, like, around season eight, they rolled out a cake for someone. Everyone's clapping and singing. And I literally said out loud, no one ever did this for me. Oh, no. And someone else was like, yeah,
我从来没有得到过。我记得，大约在第八季，他们为一个人生日推出来一个蛋糕。每个人都在鼓掌和唱歌。我真的大声说，从来没有人为我这样做过。哦，不。然后另一个人说，是的，
I have a summer birthday. Where's our summer? her birthday cake. Did they ever do it? No. I have never gotten a birthday cake at school or work. This is my crimey or river. But when I see these scenes, I just remember being like, yeah, well, where's my
我是夏季生日。我们的夏季生日蛋糕在哪里？他们做过吗？没有。我从来没有在学校或工作中得到过生日蛋糕。这是我的犯罪或河流。但当我看到这些场景时，我只是记得当时心想，是的，好吧，我的蛋糕在哪里？
cake? Oh, my God. Lady, I'm so sorry. You're right. I enjoyed many a March birthday cake by Peter and Vartan with the candles. Sometimes they would do a photo cake and put some sweet personal photo on it. Jenna, I have really. multiple photos I took of other people in their cakes.
哦，天哪。女士，我很抱歉。你是对的。我享受过许多彼得和瓦尔坦做的三月生日蛋糕，上面有蜡烛。有时他们会做一个照片蛋糕，放上一张甜蜜的个人照片。珍娜，我真的有。我拍了很多其他人吃蛋糕的照片。
Oh, no. We also did it for the crew members. I know. Yeah. Summer birthdays, S-O-L. So, listen, I turn 50 in June. I expect an office lady's birthday cake and a song and applause. Okay.
哦，不。我们也为工作人员做过。我知道。是的。夏季生日，S-O-L。所以，听着，我在六月满50岁。我期待一个办公室女士的生日蛋糕，还有歌声和掌声。好吧。
Done. Did you get that? Sam, Cassie, Cody? For once in my life, I want a work birthday. You know what, Angela? I promise we will not take a vacation the week of your birthday just so that we are forced to celebrate it. I want to work on my birthday. Yeah, that's the other thing. Everyone else is like, dude, at least you were like on vacation for your birthday. I was stuck at work. At least I got a cake. I want to work on my birthday and I want a cake. We'll make that happen for you this year, Angela. I promise.
成交。你听到了吗？萨姆，卡西，科迪？我这辈子第一次想要一个工作生日。你知道吗，安吉拉？我保证我们不会在你生日那天去度假，只是为了强迫我们庆祝它。我想在生日那天工作。是的，那是另一回事。其他人都在说，伙计，至少你生日那天在度假。我被困在工作。至少我得到了一个蛋糕。我想在生日那天工作，我想要一个蛋糕。今年我们会为你实现这一点的，安吉拉。我保证。
Thank you. I really appreciate it. Should we talk about Andy's cake demand? Yes. He wants. a Fudgy the Whale ice cream cake and pizza rolls and mushroom caps. Oh, lady, do you remember the Fudgy the Whale? Do you remember this on set? It was a big deal. I do. Because it's a special cake brand.
谢谢。我真的很感激。我们应该谈谈安迪的蛋糕要求吗？是的。他想要一个“Fudgy the Whale”冰淇淋蛋糕，还有披萨卷和蘑菇帽。哦，女士，你还记得“Fudgy the Whale”吗？你还记得片场这个吗？那是一件大事。我记得。因为它是一个特殊的蛋糕品牌。
Yes, it's Carvel, right? And I had never heard of Fudgy the Whale, which I remember a few of the crew and cast were like, are you kidding me? You've never heard of Fudgy the Whale? But it was an East Coast thing. I'd never heard of it. It's totally an East Coast thing. Well, last night, somebody might have done what she likes to call a mini dive.
是的，是Carvel，对吧？我从来没听说过“Fudgy the Whale”，我记得几个工作人员和演员说，你在开玩笑吗？你从来没听说过“Fudgy the Whale”？但那是东海岸的东西。我从来没听说过。这完全是东海岸的东西。好吧，昨晚，有人可能做了她喜欢称之为“迷你潜水”的事情。
Oh, you mini dived Fudgy the Whale. I mean, that does sound inappropriate, but I like it. There you go. All right, here's everything you need to know about Fudgy the Whale. Carvel was founded by Tom Carvel, who, by the way, is fascinating. That would be a whole other deep dive about his life and how he really gave birth to like this whole franchise ice cream phenomenon. But here's the famous story. It's on their website.
哦，你对“Fudgy the Whale”进行了迷你潜水。我的意思是，这听起来确实不合适，但我喜欢。给你。好吧，这是你需要知道的关于“Fudgy the Whale”的一切。Carvel是由汤姆·卡维尔创立的，顺便说一句，他很迷人。那将是关于他的人生以及他如何真正催生了整个特许经营冰淇淋现象的另一个深度挖掘。但这是著名的故事。它在他们的网站上。
It's in multiple places online. Legend has it. Tom Carvel had an ice cream truck that broke down, and his ice cream started to melt. So he was really trying quickly to sell off all this ice cream before it melted. And he found that the customers actually liked it soft. So he was like, wait a second. And he started serving soft serve ice cream. And no one else was doing that.
它在网上的多个地方都有。传说汤姆·卡维尔有一辆冰淇淋车坏了，他的冰淇淋开始融化。所以他真的在努力快速卖掉所有这些冰淇淋，以免它们融化。他发现顾客实际上喜欢软的。所以他心想，等一下。然后他开始供应软冰淇淋。没有其他人这样做。
Oh. And so it became a whole thing, right? He developed a soft serve ice cream machine. He even patented it. He sold it to other franchises. This man, Jenna, he was a boss lady. He was a boss dude. He was a boss daddy.
哦。所以它变成了一件大事，对吧？他开发了一台软冰淇淋机。他甚至申请了专利。他把它卖给了其他特许经营店。这个人，珍娜，他是个老板。他是个老板。他是个老板爸爸。
There we go. He was a boss daddy. And he started the very first Carville ice cream shop on the exact spot where his truck broke down. That is boss daddy. So there are Carville stores. They're franchise. There is one now in Los Angeles, Jenna. Really?
就是这样。他是个老板爸爸。他在他车坏掉的那个确切地点开了第一家Carvel冰淇淋店。那才是老板爸爸。所以有Carvel商店。它们是特许经营的。现在洛杉矶有一家，珍娜。真的吗？
There used to not be, but there is one now in Los Angeles. And they became famous for a few cakes. In the 70s, they created this cake called the cookie puss. Oh, boy. I know. The Hug Me Bear. And then Fudgy the Whale followed in June of 1977. He was all Tom Carvel's idea.
以前没有，但现在洛杉矶有一家。他们因为几个蛋糕而出名。在70年代，他们创造了这个叫“Cookie Puss”的蛋糕。哦，天哪。我知道。拥抱熊。然后“Fudgy the Whale”在1977年6月跟进。他全是汤姆·卡维尔的主意。
He was like, we need a cake for Father's Day. I want it to be a whale. And I want the slogan to say, for a whale of a dad. Oh, my God. I am loving so much about this. I looked up the expression. I've never heard of this, a whale of something. I don't know if you've heard of that expression.
他说，我们需要一个父亲节蛋糕。我想要它是一条鲸鱼。我想要口号说，“给鲸鱼般的爸爸”。哦，天哪。我非常喜欢这个。我查了这个表达。我从来没听说过这个，“a whale of something”。我不知道你是否听说过那个表达。
I hadn't. But that was an expression, and it referred to a very great amount of something or a very good thing. So to be a whale of a dad was you were a great dad, right? Fudgy the whale was so successful. They kept the mold and talk about reuse, repurpose. At Christmas time, they flipped Fudgy the Whale on its head and made his tail like the Santa hat and made them into a Santa. And to this day, you can still get Fudgy the Whale. And you can also get a female fudgy the whale.
我没听说过。但那是一个表达，它指的是非常大量的某物或非常好的东西。所以成为“a whale of a dad”就是你是一个伟大的爸爸，对吧？“Fudgy the Whale”非常成功。他们保留了模具，谈谈重复使用、重新利用。在圣诞节，他们把“Fudgy the Whale”倒过来，把他的尾巴做成圣诞帽，把它们变成了圣诞老人。直到今天，你仍然可以买到“Fudgy the Whale”。你也可以买到雌性的“Fudgy the Whale”。
Fudgy the Whale. They'll give her pink piping and like eyelashes and a little bow. And more than 50,000 Fudgy the Whale ice cream cakes are sold every year. All the cakes come with two layers of chocolate and vanilla separated by a layer of what they call crunchies. They don't tell you what's in their crunchy recipe. And you can customize it with favorite flavors and a different type of scintor. And there you have it. That's Fudgy the Whale. But I have one other thing I want to play you. Tom Carvel himself would do all the jingles and commercial. for fudgy the whale. No way!
“Fudgy the Whale”。他们会给她粉红色的装饰和睫毛，还有一个小蝴蝶结。每年售出超过50,000个“Fudgy the Whale”冰淇淋蛋糕。所有的蛋糕都有两层巧克力和香草，中间隔着一层他们称之为“crunchies”的东西。他们不告诉你他们的脆皮配方里有什么。你可以用最喜欢的口味和不同类型的装饰来定制它。这就是“Fudgy the Whale”。但我还有另一件事想放给你听。汤姆·卡维尔本人会为“Fudgy the Whale”做所有的广告歌和广告。没门！
Yeah. All right, Jenna, here's Tom Carvel talking about Fudgy the Whale for their ad. Fudgy the whale is back. That's a whale of a cake for a whale of a dad. But you participate in Carvel ice cream store.
是的。好吧，珍娜，这是汤姆·卡维尔为他们的广告谈论“Fudgy the Whale”。“Fudgy the Whale”回来了。那是给鲸鱼般的爸爸的鲸鱼般的蛋糕。但你参与Carvel冰淇淋店。
And this year, your Carvel meal makes them loaded with fudge and nuts. And you can get fudgy with an ocean to serve 20 people. But if you want to send Fudgy the whale to a whale of a dad anywhere in the Carvel territory,
今年，你的Carvel餐点让它们充满了软糖和坚果。你可以得到一个能供20人食用的“Fudgy”。但如果你想把“Fudgy the Whale”送到Carvel领地任何地方的鲸鱼般的爸爸那里，
You call them the phone number that you see here. Thank you. And have a happy day, Dad. I don't want to tip my hand too much. Am I going to get a Fudgy the Whale for my 50th birthday? How could we not get you a Fudgy the Whale now? Oh, my God. I am so excited already.
你拨打你在这里看到的电话号码。谢谢。祝你有个快乐的一天，爸爸。我不想透露太多。我会在50岁生日时得到一个“Fudgy the Whale”吗？我们现在怎么能不给你买一个“Fudgy the Whale”呢？哦，天哪。我已经很兴奋了。
I want to eat one of those so bad now that you've described it. I know. I went on Carville's website. There's so many cool-looking cakes. They do a lot more now. I'm not going to lie, the cookie puss is kind of odd looking. What? Is it a cat? I took a picture of it.
你描述完之后，我现在太想吃一个了。我知道。我上了Carvel的网站。有很多看起来很酷的蛋糕。他们现在做的更多了。我不撒谎，Cookie Puss看起来有点奇怪。什么？它是猫吗？我拍了一张照片。
Here were their first three cakes that were like their famous cakes. Okay, I can't wait for you to see this. This is the cookie puss. Oh, well, it has a full ice cream cone as a nose. Yeah. And then on its cheeks, it has little arms drawn on it. It has cookies for eyes. Are they arms?
这是他们最初的三个蛋糕，就像他们著名的蛋糕一样。好吧，我等不及让你看到这个了。这是Cookie Puss。哦，好吧，它有一个完整的冰淇淋蛋筒作为鼻子。是的。然后在它的脸颊上，它有画上去的小手臂。它有饼干作为眼睛。那是手臂吗？
What's the puss part? Is it meant to be a cat? I don't know. I don't understand what it is. Here's the best part. For St. Patrick's Day, you can get a cookie opus, the Irish version. I don't understand it. I want to eat it.
Puss部分是什么？它是想成为一只猫吗？我不知道。我不明白它是什么。这是最好的部分。在圣帕特里克节，你可以得到一个Cookie Opus，爱尔兰版本。我不明白。我想吃它。
I don't know. I went real deep onto the Carville site, but I'm very excited. I want to fudgy the whale for my 50th birthday. Done. I can't wait. I don't remember it being on set. Isn't that funny? I remember everyone talking about it.
我不知道。我深入研究了Carvel网站，但我非常兴奋。我想要一个“Fudgy the Whale”作为我的50岁生日礼物。成交。我等不及了。我不记得它在片场。那不是很滑稽吗？我记得每个人都在谈论它。
and I remember people saying, what is it? But I don't remember ever having one. I totally remember it. I mean, my character didn't eat it, but I remember Ed eating it in the scene. Wow. Well, when we eat your cake for your birthday, it's going to be all new to me. Ladies, should we go back out into the wilderness? Oh, definitely.
我记得人们说，那是什么？但我记得从来没有吃过一个。我完全记得它。我的意思是，我的角色没有吃它，但我记得艾德在场景中吃了它。哇。好吧，当我们为你生日吃你的蛋糕时，对我来说一切都是新的。女士们，我们应该回到荒野吗？哦，绝对。
We should. I have a crew catch at 13 minutes, 15 seconds. Oh, what did you catch? You can see our cinematographer Randall Einhorn's hand come into frame and brush some tree branches away that we're probably going to hit his camera. He's walking behind Dwight. Oh, Jenna, that's a great catch. I didn't see that. What's the time code?
我们应该。我在十三分十五秒有一个工作人员穿帮。哦，你抓到了什么？你可以看到我们的摄影师兰德尔·艾因霍恩的手进入画面，刷开了一些可能会撞到他摄像机的树枝。他走在德怀特后面。哦，珍娜，那是个很棒的发现。我没看到。时间码是多少？
13 minutes, 15 seconds. I was not the only person to catch it, but I want to say that I saw it before I saw our mail. But Tim Wong, Jonah T., Addie H., and Keanu Raber also wrote. in about Randall's hand. Well, great job, guys. Great job. We also had Jasper Anders and Morgan Elridge write in to ask, what did Phil Shea use for the bird eggs that Dwight finds and cooks? They kind of look like they might be small potatoes. Guess what? What? They were small potatoes. Really? Tini tiny potatoes meant to look like eggs. I totally thought they were eggs. But I I was trying to think what kind of bird makes a nest like that up in a tree.
十三分十五秒。我不是唯一发现它的人，但我想要说我在看到我们的邮件之前就看到了。但蒂姆·王、乔纳·T、艾迪·H和基努·拉伯也写信提到了兰德尔的手。好吧，干得好，伙计们。干得好。我们还有贾斯珀·安德斯和摩根·埃尔里奇写信问，菲尔·谢用什么做了德怀特发现并烹饪的鸟蛋？它们看起来有点像小土豆。猜猜怎么着？什么？它们是小土豆。真的吗？小小的土豆，看起来像蛋。我完全以为它们是蛋。但我一直在想什么样的鸟会在树上筑那样的巢。
What? What? Many birds? So many birds? That was such a big nest, though. Like, those eggs look like a bird that would, like, lay them on the ground to me. Or, I mean, I guess, what? Or maybe they're the eggs of a bird that would nest really up high. Exactly. They didn't look like the type of eggs that you could just reach with your hand. I think you would either find them on the ground or they'd be up on a cliff top. I think that that's a good way to say it. When you said what kind of bird lays eggs in a tree, I was confused. But I'm hearing your point now, and I hear it, and I think it's a good point.
什么？什么？很多鸟？很多鸟？那个巢太大了。那些蛋看起来像那种会把它们产在地上的鸟。或者，我的意思是，我猜，什么？或者也许它们是那种会筑在高处的鸟的蛋。完全正确。它们看起来不像那种你可以用手够到的蛋。我认为你要么会在地上找到它们，要么它们会在悬崖顶上。我认为这是一个很好的说法。当你问什么样的鸟在树上产蛋时，我很困惑。但我现在听到了你的观点，我听到了，我认为这是一个很好的观点。
Thank you. I need to talk about this shot of Michael singing Happy Birthday, because it is just wonderful. Oh, Michael has just made a spear. The teeniest tiniest tiniest spear on the end of a very crooked stick. I want to point out that he made a spear when he has an amazing knife, like you would think he would attach the knife to the end of the stick. With his duct tape. With his duct tape.
谢谢。我需要谈谈迈克尔唱生日快乐歌的那个镜头，因为它太美妙了。哦，迈克尔刚刚做了一根长矛。在一根非常弯曲的棍子末端做了一根最小最小最小的长矛。我想指出，他做了一根长矛，但他有一把很棒的刀，你会认为他会把刀绑在棍子的末端。用他的胶带。用他的胶带。
He might have used all his duct tape to fashion his tent out of his pants. That's coming up, I guess. But yeah, there's this shot that pulls so far back. And what's amazing about it to me is, guys, Steve was really in the middle of nowhere and our crew was far back as this shot reveals. Yeah. I thought it was a beautiful shot. I also love these moments when Michael remembers things like sprinkles, like Creed's birthday, you know, and he sings a song and he's like, happy birthday, buddy. Yeah.
他可能用他所有的胶带把他的裤子做成了帐篷。我想那快到了。但是的，有一个镜头拉得很远。对我来说，它令人惊奇的是，伙计们，史蒂夫真的在荒郊野外，我们的工作人员像这个镜头揭示的那样远。是的。我认为这是一个美丽的镜头。我也喜欢这些迈克尔记得像Sprinkles、克里德的生日这样的事情的时刻，你知道，他唱了一首歌，他说，生日快乐，伙计。是的。
These are those very sweet Michael moments. This shot also made me think about how Steve Carell wrote this episode. He wrote himself a very difficult shoot day out in the woods. He did, where he gets tackled by Dwight. Oh, my gosh. If I were writing an episode for myself, I would make it Pajama Day at the office, where we all wear our pajamas and there are no stunts. I would write a very different episode.
这些是非常甜蜜的迈克尔时刻。这个镜头也让我想到史蒂夫·卡瑞尔是如何写这一集的。他为自己写了一个在树林里非常艰难的拍摄日。他确实写了，他被德怀特扑倒。哦，天哪。如果我要为自己写一集，我会把它写成办公室的睡衣日，我们都穿睡衣，没有特技。我会写一集非常不同的。
So I applaud Steve for really going for it in the name of comedy. Back in the office, we have bitching in the break room. Oh, I love this. Everyone is in the break room and they are complaining about Jim's new birthday ordinance. And it's just a gripe fest. Look what I wrote as part of the scene. I've never had a cake at work for my birthday. Wow. As everyone was griping about the cakes and the birthdays.
所以我为史蒂夫以喜剧的名义真正去尝试而鼓掌。回到办公室，我们在休息室里抱怨。哦，我喜欢这个。每个人都在休息室里，他们正在抱怨吉姆的新生日条例。这简直是一场抱怨大会。看看我作为场景的一部分写了什么。我生日那天在工作中从来没有吃过蛋糕。哇。当每个人都在抱怨蛋糕和生日时。
Angela, this episode really triggered you. Apparently so. Right about this time Jim walks in and Creed delivers some major sass. Oh, Creed sass. Some real, real good passive-acgressive sass from Creed. And right after some real serious Creed sass, Jim is going to have to deal with Toby. Oh, this is such a good. scene. It's so good. And you see in Jim's eyes, oh my God, Michael, I get it. Yeah, he has a
安吉拉，这一集真的触发了你。显然是这样。就在这时吉姆走了进来，克里德发表了一些主要的讽刺。哦，克里德的讽刺。来自克里德的真正、真正好的被动攻击性讽刺。在一些非常严肃的克里德讽刺之后，吉姆将不得不处理托比。哦，这是一个非常好的场景。太好了。你在吉姆的眼睛里看到了，哦，天哪，迈克尔，我明白了。是的，他有一个
talking head where he says. You know, Toby is sometimes a bit much. Yeah, I know. Well, listen, Toby's birthday is not right now. And he's piling on Jim. He says, I'd really like to be included because when we did celebrate my birthday, it was in the parking lot at 4.58 p.m. And so, Toby would now like to be included. Jenna, am I the Toby of this moment today? No, am I the Toby? Am I like, I know it's not my birthday, but I want to be included. Am I the Toby?
采访片段，他说。你知道，托比有时有点过分。是的，我知道。好吧，听着，托比的生日不是现在。他在给吉姆施压。他说，我真的很想被包括在内，因为当我们庆祝我的生日时，是在下午4点58分的停车场。所以，托比现在想被包括在内。珍娜，我是今天这个时刻的托比吗？不，我是托比吗？我是那种，我知道这不是我的生日，但我想要被包括在内。我是托比吗？
Well, you're not asking us to throw you a party on someone else's birthday. You're just saying, this year, don't skip my eff' birthday just because it's in the summer. I think it's very different. Thank you. Jim agrees to just add Toby to the mix. And Angela overhears this. She's so furious. She's like, you can't go willy-nilly with all of this, Jim.
好吧，你没有要求我们在别人的生日那天为你举办派对。你只是说，今年，不要因为我的生日在夏天就跳过它。我认为这非常不同。谢谢。吉姆同意把托比加进去。安吉拉听到了这个。她非常愤怒。她说，你不能随心所欲地做这一切，吉姆。
You know, we already have several cakes and a pie and mushroom caps. And Toby's like, I'm allergic to mushrooms. Well, that's the last straw. Jim storms out of his office and he says, conference room. And Pam's like five minutes. And he's like, yes, conference room. room five minutes. And he's like, no, I mean, no, we're going to deal with this right here. I have something to point out in this scene. It's a little background catch.
你知道，我们已经有几个蛋糕、一个派和蘑菇帽了。托比说，我对蘑菇过敏。好吧，那是最后一根稻草。吉姆冲出他的办公室说，会议室。帕姆说五分钟。他说，是的，会议室五分钟。他说，不，我的意思是，不，我们要在这里处理这个问题。我在这场戏里有一点要指出。这是一个小背景发现。
Okay. Both Creed and Meredith have a free cell game open on their computer. I have a little background catch in this scene as well. At 17 minutes, 36 seconds, I am leaning up against Michael's doorframe, standing next to Toby, and you can see the beginning of my baby belly. Oh my gosh, are you serious? I am serious and I rewatched this episode with my daughter and I didn't say anything to her. And as she was watching it with me, we got to the scene and she said, Mom, is this when you were pregnant with me?
好吧。克里德和梅雷迪思的电脑上都开着一个空当接龙游戏。我在这场戏里也有一个小背景发现。在十七分三十六秒，我靠在迈克尔的门框上，站在托比旁边，你可以看到我婴儿肚子的开始。哦，天哪，你是认真的吗？我是认真的，我和我女儿重看了这一集，我什么也没对她说。当她和我一起看的时候，我们到了那个场景，她说，妈妈，这是你怀我的时候吗？
And I said, it was. Look, Jenna. Oh my gosh. And you have your hands in front of your stomach to kind of try to hide it. But, Angie, I thought I could kind of see it earlier in the episode when you have your first scene walking up to Jim's desk. Really? They tried to position you a little bit behind his computer screen, but maybe because I know, I felt like I had a belly spot. Well, this will be the beginning of the belly tracking, because we had to get really creative over the next few weeks. I'm ready to head back out to the
我说，是的。看，珍娜。哦，天哪。你把手放在肚子前面试图遮住它。但是，安吉拉，我觉得我在这一集早些时候当你第一次走到吉姆桌子前时就看到了。真的吗？他们试图把你稍微放在他的电脑屏幕后面，但也许因为我知道，我觉得我有一个肚子点。好吧，这将是肚子追踪的开始，因为我们在接下来的几周里必须非常有创意。我准备好回到
forest, Angela. Okay. Because I have a lot to say about this scene where Michael finds some mushrooms growing under a tree and he starts to eat them and Dwight tackles him and forces them out of his mouth. It's pretty amazing. It's so great. I had to know more about these mushrooms. What'd you find out? According to Dundropedia, the species of mushroom that Michael was about to eat are called hyphaloma fasciculari.
森林了，安吉拉。好的。因为关于迈克尔在树下发现一些蘑菇并开始吃它们，而德怀特扑倒他并强迫它们从他嘴里吐出来的那个场景，我有很多话要说。太棒了。我必须更多地了解这些蘑菇。你发现了什么？根据Dundropedia，迈克尔正要吃的蘑菇种类被称为“Hypholoma fasciculare”。
I'm sure I got that wrong. I would never be able to say that. They are more commonly known as the clustered wood lover. Okay. I deep dived on these mushrooms. I'm guessing they grow on wood. They do. It is a type of mushroom and they grow on rotten trees, stumps, or trunks.
我肯定我弄错了。我永远也说不出那个名字。它们更常被称为“簇生木恋者”。好吧。我深度挖掘了这些蘑菇。我猜它们长在木头上。它们确实长在木头上。这是一种蘑菇，它们长在腐烂的树木、树桩或树干上。
The taste is very bitter if you eat them raw, but they are not bitter if you cook them. They are poisonous. Either way, cooked or raw. Why would anyone cook them if they're poisonous? How do we even know what they taste like? I'll tell you, because a common poisoning technique would be to cook these mushrooms with non-poisonous mushrooms and then feed them to your enemy. And it's sort of like an undetectable way to poison someone to death. So morbid.
如果你生吃它们，味道非常苦，但如果你煮熟它们，它们就不苦了。它们是有毒的。无论如何，煮熟或生吃。如果它们有毒，为什么有人会煮它们？我们怎么知道它们是什么味道的？我告诉你，因为一种常见的投毒技术是把这些蘑菇和无毒的蘑菇一起煮，然后喂给你的敌人。这是一种无法检测到的毒死人的方法。太可怕了。
So clearly this has been done. Yeah. Did you see the movie Phantom Thread starring Daniel Day-Lewis? Because this is a plot point in the movie. No, and if you tell me to watch it, I'm going to watch the first 15 minutes of it. Well, you're going to miss the mushrooms because they happen later. Let me tell you. What?
所以很明显这已经有人做过了。是的。你看过丹尼尔·戴-刘易斯主演的电影《魅影缝匠》吗？因为这是电影中的一个情节。没有，如果你告诉我去看它，我会看它的前15分钟。好吧，你会错过蘑菇，因为它们发生在后面。让我告诉你。什么？
Here's what happens to you if you eat these mushrooms. Okay. Diarrhea. Okay. Nausea. Mm. Vomiting. Bovulsions.
如果你吃这些蘑菇会发生什么。好吧。腹泻。好吧。恶心。嗯。呕吐。抽搐。
Impaired vision. Paralysis and collapse. Geez. It can take up to five to ten hours before you get symptoms. Now, most of the time, the symptoms will. will resolve themselves after a few days, but you get real sick, but they can cause death if you eat too many. So guys, spoiler alert, Phantom Thread is an amazing movie. Everyone should watch it. I'm not going to watch it. As if anyone's ever going to take my movie recommendations again.
视力受损、瘫痪和虚脱。天哪。从出现症状到发作可能需要五到十个小时。大多数情况下，症状会在几天后自行消失，但如果你吃得太多，还是会病得很重，甚至导致死亡。伙计们，剧透预警，《魅影缝匠》是一部很棒的电影，每个人都应该看。我才不看呢。好像还会有人再听我的电影推荐似的。
I did watch this one all the way through twice. I loved it so much. Stop listening here for 10 seconds if you don't want me to spoil the movie for you, but someone gets poisoned with mushrooms. Do they have a little towel by their coffee pot? No, but they have a wonderful English kitchen that looks like it's really fun to cook in. So there is some great shots of a great kitchen. I'll be sure and check out the shots of the kitchen. Oh, my God. Let John Wick go, Angela. Let it go.
这部电影我完整看了两遍。我太喜欢了。如果你不想被剧透，现在就暂停10秒，不过电影里有人被蘑菇毒死了。他们的咖啡壶旁边有小毛巾吗？没有，但他们有一个很棒的英式厨房，看起来在里面做饭一定很有趣。所以里面有一些很棒的厨房镜头。我一定会去看看那些厨房的镜头。天哪，安吉拉，放过疾速追杀吧。放过它吧。
Maybe once you get your Carvel cake, you'll forgive me. Once I join everyone who's ever celebrated their birthday at work or school. Anyway, that is the download on the mushrooms. Well, you know the scene where Dwight tackles Michael to the ground? Yeah. There was much more of this in the deleted scenes. There is a great talking head where Michael's like, you know, when Dwight tackled me to the ground and was fishing the mushrooms out of my mouth with his finger,
也许等你拿到你的卡维尔蛋糕，你就会原谅我了。等我加入那些在工作或学校庆祝生日的人的行列之后。总之，这就是关于蘑菇的全部信息。对了，你知道德怀特把迈克尔扑倒在地的那一幕吗？是的。删减片段里还有很多这样的内容。有一个很棒的采访片段，迈克尔说，你知道，当德怀特把我扑倒在地，用手指从我嘴里抠出蘑菇时，
He says it. He's like when Dwight had his finger in my mouth, he said, I laid back and I looked at the sky and the birds were chirping and there were clouds and it was so beautiful. And then I vomited because it was really gross. It's really funny that he had this sort of beautiful moment while Dwight was trying to fish the mushrooms out of his mouth. I have to ask, is that talking head? Is he wearing his torn up clothes or is he wearing Dwight's sweatshirt? No, it would have been like a wrap-up talking head about his day and he was in his office with the Battlestar Galactica sweatshirt. Well, I love this idea that his clothes are tattered. He's probably vomited on them. And Dwight has to give him this rescue sweatshirt that was in his trunk. Well, Jenna, I want you to know at 18 minutes, 31 seconds, when Dwight and Michael come back and they walk in the party and Michael immediately starts hitting those high notes, right? he doesn't miss a beat. The camera pans the conference room.
他是这么说的。他说当德怀特的手指伸进我嘴里时，我躺在那里看着天空，鸟儿在鸣叫，云朵飘浮，一切都那么美好。然后我就吐了，因为真的很恶心。他能在德怀特试图从他嘴里抠出蘑菇时有这种美好的时刻，真是太搞笑了。我得问问，那个采访片段里，他穿的是那件破烂的衣服，还是穿的德怀特的运动衫？不，那应该是关于他这一天经历的总结采访，他当时在办公室里，穿着那件《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》的运动衫。好吧，我喜欢他衣服破破烂烂的设定。他可能吐在上面了。德怀特不得不把后备箱里的那件备用运动衫给他穿。对了，珍娜，我想让你知道，在18分31秒时，当德怀特和迈克尔回来走进派对，迈克尔立刻开始唱起高音，对吧？他一点都没跑调。镜头扫过了会议室。
And Toby, Pam, Angela, and Oscar are all standing together. And they are smiling so big. And I thought, oh, my God, Toby and Angela are happy to see Michael and Oscar. Yeah. Like, I expect Pam to smile at him, you know. But the fact that Toby and Angela were relieved to see Michael. Well, they did not enjoy Jim being in charge. No.
托比、帕姆、安吉拉和奥斯卡都站在一起。他们笑得非常灿烂。我想，天哪，托比和安吉拉见到迈克尔和奥斯卡居然这么开心。是的。就像，我预料到帕姆会对他笑，你知道的。但托比和安吉拉见到迈克尔时如释重负，这事实在是……好吧，他们确实不喜欢吉姆掌权。
We had a fan catch in this. seen, Angela. Okay. From Andrea T. who would like to know who made the peach cobbler for Creed because it's in a Pyrex dish. It's clearly homemade. Did Angela go home and make this cobbler because she is so dedicated to throwing the perfect birthday party? So listen, I thought about this too. And I think Angela did. I think when Creed said to Jim, tell Angela it's for Creed, she'll know what to do. Angela went home and made his favorite peach cobbler pie. I'm impressed. Mm-hmm.
安吉拉，这一幕里我们有一个粉丝发现的细节。好的。来自安德里亚·T，她想知道是谁给克里德做的桃子脆皮馅饼，因为它装在派热克斯玻璃盘里。显然是自制的。安吉拉是不是回家做了这个馅饼，因为她致力于举办完美的生日派对？听着，我也想过这个问题。我觉得是安吉拉做的。我觉得当克里德对吉姆说告诉安吉拉这是给克里德的，她就会知道该怎么做时，安吉拉回家做了他最喜欢的桃子脆皮馅饼。我很佩服。嗯哼。
Well, at 18 minutes, 56 seconds, you guys, there is a great shot of the Fudgy the Whale cake. Oh, so there you go. It was there, proof of fudgy. Proof of fudgy. And, Jenna, as we're wrapping up this scene, Jim and Michael have this fantastic moment where Jim is like, I tried to do all of their parties on one day. And Michael's like, oh, yeah, I did that. Yeah, rookie mistake. You'll figure it out.
好吧，在18分56秒，伙计们，有一个很棒的“福吉鲸鱼”蛋糕的镜头。哦，你看，它就在那儿，福吉存在的证据。福吉的证据。而且，珍娜，在我们结束这一幕时，吉姆和迈克尔有一个非常精彩的时刻，吉姆说，我试着把他们的派对都安排在同一天。迈克尔说，哦，是的，我做过。是的，新手常犯的错误。你会弄明白的。
This scene is so beautiful. It's this glimpse into Michael where he's kind of talking to a peer, right? He's always managering us or always wanting to be in that position of status to us. But here he is talking manager on manager to Jim. It's amazing. It's so great. And it's such a human moment. You know, Jim's like, I'm not going to be here in 10 years.
这一幕太美了。这是对迈克尔的一次窥探，他当时是在和同僚交谈，对吧？他总是以经理自居，或者总是想在我们面前保持那种地位。但在这里，他正以经理对经理的身份和吉姆交谈。太棒了。这是一个非常人性化的时刻。你知道，吉姆说，我十年后不会在这里了。
And Michael's like, yeah, that's what I said. So as we close out this episode, Jenna, I thought we could hear just the final end of Jim and Michael's scene together. Sam, can you play that? Sure glad you're back. You are relieved. You have no idea. So what did I miss? Well, I tried to put all the birthdays together at once. Oh. So terrible idea.
迈克尔说，是的，我也是这么说的。所以当我们结束这一集时，珍娜，我想我们可以听听吉姆和迈克尔最后那段对话的结尾。萨姆，你能放一下吗？很高兴你回来了。你如释重负。你根本不知道。那我错过了什么？嗯，我试着把所有的生日聚会放在一起办。哦。真是个糟糕的主意。
Yeah. Okay. I did that. Rooker mistake. You did do it? Uh-huh. No. Let's wait. Ten years, you'll figure it out. Well, I don't think I'll be here in ten years. That's what I said. That's what she said.
是的。好吧。我做过。新手错误。你真的做过？嗯哼。不。等等。十年后，你会弄明白的。好吧，我不觉得我十年后还会在这里。我也是这么说的。这就是她说的。
That's what who said? I never know. I just say it. I say stuff like that, you know, to lighten the tension when things sort of get hard. That's what she said. Hey, nice. Really good.
是谁说的？我从来都不知道。我只是随口一说。我会说这种话，你知道的，为了在情况变得棘手时缓解紧张气氛。这就是她说的。嘿，不错。真的很好。
Bravo, my young ward. I have a question. Yeah. Is Michael finally eating what was in the bag? It sounds like he's eating nuts. Yeah, I looked at it, and it's like, I can't tell what they are, little pretzel bites. You know what they look like? If you get a checks mix, there are these little stubby pretzel bite things.
干得好，我的年轻门徒。我有个问题。什么？迈克尔终于在吃袋子里的东西了吗？听起来像是在吃坚果。是的，我看了，就像，我看不出那是什么，小椒盐卷饼块。你知道它们看起来像什么吗？如果你买切克斯混合零食，里面就有那种粗短的椒盐卷饼块。
I don't know. Or they look like slivered omens. Or pecans? It's such a mystery. But as I watched that lovely scene that I absolutely love, I was wondering, what is he eating? I'd forgotten about it. I'll have to go back and look. Well, you guys, that was Survivor Man. I don't think I'd make it out in the woods. I do think I'd make it at party planning. I'd make sure everyone had their dang cake. Next week, we have the deposition that has some of my favorite scenes of all time. Brilliant. Thank you so much for listening. Thank you for sending in your questions and your comments.
我不知道。或者它们看起来像切片的杏仁。还是山核桃？这真是一个谜。但当我观看那段我绝对喜欢的精彩场景时，我在想，他在吃什么？我把它忘了。我得回去看看。好吧，伙计们，这就是《幸存者》。我觉得我在树林里可活不下去。但我确实觉得我在派对策划方面能行。我会确保每个人都有他们该死的蛋糕。下周，我们将播出听证会，里面有一些我这辈子最喜欢的场景。太棒了。非常感谢大家的收听。感谢你们发来的问题和评论。
We love it. We love you guys. Everyone send Angela a cake on her birthday. No, no, no. Oh, my gosh. All right. Bye, guys. Bye.
我们很喜欢。我们爱你们。大家在安吉拉生日那天给她寄个蛋糕吧。不，不，不。天哪。好了。再见，伙计们。再见。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' second drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jirkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。本集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·吉尔金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是莫莉·纽金特。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。